e jeu
vais vous faire un coup
on va dire deux objets qui vont vous
accompagner tout au long de votre vie
personnelle et professionnelle à partir
de maintenant est du reste depuis le
passé qui s'appelle l'énergie et le
changement climatique
alors je ne suis pas académique mon
métier c'est d'être consultant je suis
associé d'une société de conseil jai un
deuxième métier qui est président d'une
association et je fais de la
vulgarisation qui a fini par donner lieu
à secours
c'est le pourquoi je fais ce métier
plutôt que mon métier principal le court
que je vais vous faire est
essentiellement un court basé sur des
données d'observation des raisonnements
relativement simple avec les mains
j'espère que ça sera accessible c'est
pas très différent pour être très franc
d'un certain nombre de choses que je
peux raconter dans d'autres enceintes
pour des publics qui n'ont pas été
soigneusement sélectionnés sur concours
donc normalement devrait vous devriez
arriver à suivre je vais quand même vous
rappeler deux ou trois petites choses en
entrée la première c'est que vous
retiendrez beaucoup plus facilement ce
que je raconte si vous prenez des notes
même si derrière vous les mettez à la
poubelle plutôt que si vous n'en prenez
pas donc c'est un très bon moyen de
niveaux techniques de prendre des notes
la deuxième chose c'est que je vais
essayer notamment de vous inviter à
toujours abordé les problèmes en
raisonnant par ordre de grandeur et
règle de trois vous êtes rentré dans
cette école en ayant été soigneusement
sélectionnés sur votre aptitude à
résoudre de manière en étant candidat en
ayant une aptitude supérieure à la
moyenne à résoudre des problèmes
compliqués poser de manière exacte
d'accord on vous a sélectionné pour
entrer dans cette école en vous posant
des problèmes qui sont univoques
ils ont une seule solution soit un peu
compliqué mais ils ont une seule
solution et ils sont bien posées c'est à
dire que dans l'énoncé vous avez toutes
les informations pour trouver la
solution
la vie est ce que je vais vous raconter
à partir de maintenant c'est
essentiellement fait de problèmes mal
posée où vous n'avez pas toutes les
informations
d'accord et quand on aborde un problème
qui est mal posée on n'a pas toutes les
informations il ya quelque chose qui est
extrêmement efficace pour aborder ces
problèmes ça va être particulièrement
vrai dans ce que je vais vous raconter
ses de raisonner par ordre de grandeur
et règle de trois est partout dans votre
vie si un modèle sophistiqué n'est pas
raccord avec une règle de trois bien
poser c'est que le modèle à tort
donc voilà donc cessé quelques éléments
que je vous donne en préambule sur le
court que nous allons avoir plaisir vous
parcourir ensemble
voici un des retraités les plus célèbres
de france les retraités parce qu'il
paraît qu'il a dit qu'il allait arrêter
de bosser en fait ça d'après tout à fait
vrai parce que de temps en temps on le
voit faire des trucs moins rigolo que ça
peu importe donc on va lui faire
reprendre un peu de services quand vous
posez une question à qui le gagner des
millions pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
déjà regardé cet excellent jeu vous
savez que l'on vous donne les réponses à
l'avant c'est-à-dire qu'on vous dit
voilà
l'élève qui est assis là au deuxième
rang at il une chemise petite table le
petit bever petit c'est jaune petit des
noirs et tous ceux qui en ce moment est
en train de roupiller se plantent les
autres ou la bonne réponse
là on va imaginer qu'il pose la question
de manière ouverte c'est-à-dire qu'il
vous demande c'est quoi
l'énergie savait qu'en france il ya
ministre de l'énergie donc vous pourriez
lui demander c'est quoi l'énergie
normalement il doit savoir puisqu'il
ministre de l'énergie eh bien vous vous
rendriez compte si vous posiez la
question je vous donne un exemple dans
pas longtemps que en fait la première
réponse qui vient à l'essentiel de la
population je dis bien l'essentiel de la
population donc je ne parle pas du monde
dans lequel vous évoluez au quotidien
c'est ça c'est à dire que si vous dites
énergie dans un certain nombre
d'enceintes et en particulier dans une
enceinte qu'on qualifie entre l'yvette
grand public
la première donnée qui va venir à
l'esprit de beaucoup de gens et en fait
c'est normal parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est aussi la première façon de
présenter l'énergie dans le monde des
économistes c'est c'est quelque chose
qui s'achète une commodité c'est un truc
qui s'achète et donc le sujet principal
c'est de savoir si c'est cher ou pas
cher et si on pourrait s'y prendre
autrement pour avoir la même chose qu'au
moins cher et c'est particulièrement
vrai dans l'actualité puisque pour tous
ceux d'entre vous qui ont un peu suivi
ce genre de mouvement vous savez que ça
a démarré d'une contestation sur le prix
des carburants
alors bien évidemment c'est pas ça qui
est le ressort principal infiné mais ça
a démarré par cette contestation qui
était une contestation sur le prix des
carburants donc les gilet jaune dont
j'avais dit on veut pas consommer de
carburant parce que ça fait trop de co2
où on veut pas conserver de carburant
parce que ça nous fait dépendre de la
russie de la norvège et qu'on n'a pas
envie non
il disait juste c'est trop cher alors ce
que je vais essayer de vous expliquer
pendant une partie du reste de secours
c'est que si vous prenez le problème
sous texte sous cet angle
malheureusement vous passez à côté de
l'essentiel
il ya plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles
on passe à côté de l'essentiel
la première c'est que si vous regardez
en termes strictement économique
ce que ça coûte d'acheter de l'énergie
rapporté à ce qu'on gagne et vous pouvez
leur présenter de plusieurs manières
une des manières que j'ai de leur
présenter c'est de regarder ce que ça
coûte d'acheter chaque année
l'ensemble de l'économie d'acheter le
pétrole le gaz et le charbon qui l'a
fait fonctionner d'accord donc je
regarde l'ensemble du produit économique
de l'année et je regarde rapporté à ce
produit économique ce que coûte
d'acheter sur le marché
l'ensemble du pétrole qu'on consomme
dans l'année l'ensemble du gascon
consomment dans l'année je parle pour le
monde dans son ensemble et l'ensemble du
charbon qu'on consomme dans l'année et
bien le résultat auquel j'arrive c'est
que ça coûte quelques pourcents de ce
qu'on gagne quelques pour cent de ceux
qu'on gagne je vous montrerai un
graphique dans pas très longtemps sur ce
que ça coûte pour les français d'acheter
de l'énergie et je vous assure que de
payer free sfr ou orange par l'enjeu
mais nommer personne pour dire à nos
chiens en retard ou thé où ça coûte
globalement le même prix à peu près le
même prix ça coûte quelques pourcents de
ce qu'on gagne et à partir du moment où
un objet placé dans un débat économique
représente quelques pourcents du débat
et bien à ce moment le réflexe normal ça
va être de dire je vais m'en occuper
quelques pour cent du temps est
typiquement ce que vous voyez à ce
moment dans les débats politiques c'est
je m'intéresse à l'énergie au moment des
élections
quelques pour cent du temps puis le
reste du temps je colle ça à quelqu'un à
qui je délègue le problème en lui disant
démerdez vous dans votre coin pour que
ce truc là soit géré c'est pas vraiment
mon problème je vois pas le lien avec
les retraites avec la diplomatie avec la
politique économique ou avec le nombre
d'imprimeur qu'il ya dans le pays
il n'y a pas de lien donc je vais
considérer que c'est un sujet détachable
du reste qui nécessite quelques % de mon
temps
lorsque je vais vous dire à partir de
maintenant c'est que ce raisonnement est
aussi pertinent que si je vous disais
votre cervelle ces 2 % de votre poids
donc je peux vous la supprimer c'est pas
très grave
vous allez perdre 2 % en efficacité donc
les raisonnements part de camembert et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est plus
large que simplement l'énergie les
raisonnements part de camembert ne vous
disent jamais si les parts de camembert
sont asservis les unes aux autres
ou pas il ya un autre raisonnement
cocasse de ce même type qui est de dire
l'agriculture c'est 2% du pib dont on
s'en fout on peut on peut la bazar décès
a pas beaucoup d'importance
bah oui sauf que si vous arrêtez de
manger les 98 % restants du pib assez
rapidement vont être problématique donc
les raisonnements part de camembert il
faut toujours beaucoup se méfier
sur le fait que ça ne représente pas la
dépendance que vous pouvez avoir d'une
part de camembert à une autre est ce que
je vais vous montrer maintenant c'est
que en fait la dépendance des 97 ou 98
ou 95 % du pib qui ne sont pas de
l'achat d'énergie en fait dépendent
totalement à 100% dans le monde moderne
des 5% en question donc l'énergie n'est
pas une facture même si enfin
objectivement ça n'est pas qu'une
facture même si c'est comme ça que l'on
raisonne dans le monde économique dans
lequel nous vivons
il ya une autre pensée qui vient souvent
à l'esprit quand on parle d'énergie
c'est des gens qui vous disent à
l'énergie la bonne énergie c'est celle
qu'on économise alors deuxième chose que
je vais vous montrer pendant ce court
c'est que là si vous êtes en ce moment
dans cette salle avec le temps au choix
de dormir pour que ceux qui font la
sieste ou d'écouter au lieu d'être en
train de ramasser des patates c'est
précisément parce que le monde sait
goberger d'énergie de façon croissante
sur les deux siècles qui viennent de
s'écouler pardon donc en fait le
résultat du monde dans lequel nous
vivons aujourd'hui c'est un monde
d'abondance énergétique croissante et
pas du tout un mode d'économie d'énergie
croissante
donc en fait la bonne énergie au sens de
celle qui a permis l'émergence de la
civilisation industrielle dans laquelle
on vit c'est justement celle qu'on n'a
pas économisé troisième sujet très à la
mode en ce moment c'est que
l'énergie c'est pas très grave de savoir
ce que c'est ce qui est important c'est
que ça va devenir 100 % renouvelable
vous allez voir que en fait c'est pas
exactement comme ça que les choses se
sont passées et en fait la bonne manière
d'approcher l'énergie pourrait être
celle du poète c'est à dire ceux dont
vous êtes rempli en maintenant vous êtes
en forme vous savez que quand vous êtes
un matin vous êtes en forme c'est plein
d'énergie ou une après midi ça dépend
leur laquelle vous lever et bien en fait
cette manière de voir les choses c'est
la bonne parce que quand on considère
qu'on est plein d'énergie en fait ce que
ça veut dire c'est qu'on considère qu'on
a une grande capacité à maîtriser son
destin
j'ai beaucoup d'énergie je suis très en
forme ça veut dire en gros il ya pas
grand chose qui me fait peur
et donc j'ai une grande capacité à
maîtriser mon destin or l'énergie ce
qu'on va voir à partir de maintenant
c'est que en avoir beaucoup
c'est précisément avoir une grande
capacité à maîtriser son environnement
c'est ça par définition quand par
définition avoir beaucoup d'énergie
c'est avoir une grande capacité à
maîtriser son environnement
et pourquoi ça parce que l'énergie avant
d'être une facture ou avant d'être un
objet de débat c est une grandeur
physique donc vous le savez puisque vous
avez fait un tout petit peu de physique
pour arriver dans cet amphi l'énergie
c'est une grandeur physique si assez
rigolo du reste parce qu'en physique y a
pas de définition totalement univoque de
l'énergie je vais vous en proposer une
pour moi l'énergie c'est ce qui
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système encore l'énergie cse qui
quantifie je dis bien quantifie calcule
le changement d'état d'un système dit
autrement plus le monde qui vous entoure
change plus il ya d'énergie qui est
rentré en jeu plus il ya d'énergie qui
rentrent en jeu plus le monde autour de
vous se transforme
c'est aussi simple que ça alors si je
ramène ça à des transformations de la
vie courante
en voici quelques unes ou plus
exactement à des objets qui transforme
l'environnement dans la vie courante
voici des objets qui transforme la
température corse et des objets qui sont
destinés à changer une température ce
que je vous montre la soie la réchaud à
réchauffer et soit à refroidir et ses
objets utilisent ou éventuellement
restitue de l'énergie voici des objets à
changer une vitesse une voiture ça ne
sert qu'à ça sert à changer la vitesse
de ce qui est contenu dans la voiture
vous éventuellement et vos valises quand
vous partez en vacances et bien un
changement de vitesse c'est un
changement d'état
d'un système voici des objets à changer
une forme
vous aviez de la terre la terre et
excavés elle est posée à côté du trou
changement de forme
vous aviez une tôle la tôle et emboutit
et vous avez une portière de voiture
changement de forme ces machines
utilisent de l'énergie vous avez de
l'énergie qui intervient quand vous
changez une composition chimique et soit
dit en passant la première composition
chimique qui changent en permanence pour
fournir de l'énergie dans votre univers
proche ça s'appelle votre digestion des
aliments que vous mangez en fait ils
servent à ça ils servent à fournir de
l'énergie
vous avez de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu quand vous avez des champs
magnétiques qui interagissent avec des
courants électriques
alors ça peut à la fois ça peut soit
entre guillemets en consommer dans un
moteur soit entre guillemets en fournir
dans un alternateur vous avez l'énergie
qui entrent en jeu quand vous réarranger
les nucléons d'un noyau et vous savez
que le soleil passe son temps à faire ça
1 il c'est une grosse bombe
thermonucléaire permanente qui passe son
temps à assembler des noyaux d'hydrogène
pour faire des noyaux d'hélium
vous avez de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu quand vous avez des interactions
matière rayonnement alors l'interaction
matière rayonnement qui vous intéresse
le plus c'est le smartphone mais enfin
il n'y a pas que celle-là dans les
interactions en matière rayonnement uv
qui va beaucoup vous intéressez mois
aussi durs est dans un mois et demi
représenté par cette jeune femme à
droite donc d'une manière générale
utiliser de l'énergie
ça n'est rien d'autre que transformer le
monde qui nous entoure et inversement
transformer le monde qui nous entoure
suppose nécessairement qu'il y ait de
l'énergie qu'ils soient entrés en jeu
alors une fois que je vous ai dit sa
première petite remarque
l'homme est en transition et d'absolu
qu'en ce moment on a un ministère de la
transition énergétique et pas seulement
un ministère de l'énergie est un mystère
de la transition énergétique et bien le
ministère de la transition énergétique
est probablement le plus vieux ministère
qui soit dans la communauté des hommes
puisque ça fait cinq cent mille ans que
les hommes sont en transition
énergétique
il ya cinq cent mille ans la seule
énergie que les hommes pouvaient
utiliser c'était leurs énergies
corporelles et puis sont mis à
domestiquer le feu donc une première
énergie extracorporelle dans l'antiquité
on s'est mis à domestiquer toutes les
énergies renouvelables et soit dit en
passant même quelques énergies fossiles
par exemple le pétrole était connue des
sumériens
le charbon était connue des chinois il
ya quelques milliers d'années c'est
alors à des petites doses un tout ça est
en fait la révolution industrielle a été
la domestication des énergies fossiles
on va y revenir et donc le la transition
énergétique
c'est un état permanent des hommes à
chaque fois qu'ils arrivent à trouver la
manière de se servir d'une nouvelle
source d'énergie ils le font ce qui
caractérise leur moderne et vous allez
voir que ça la caractérise de manière
extrêmement forte et que c'est ça qui
pose problème c'est que nous avons
radicalement changé d'ordre de grandeur
dans tous ses processus
en l'espace de très très peu de temps
alors l'énergie
je voulais 10 est une grandeur physique
à partir du moment où j'ai dit que
l'énergie était une grandeur physique ça
veut dire qu'il ya toutes les chances
que l'énergie soit gouvernée par des
lois que nous ne pouvons pas changer
c'est ça le charme des lois de la
physique
c'est que vous pouvez comprendre ce que
sont les équations de maxwell mais une
fois que vous avez compris vous pouvez
pas les changer vous pouvez pas dire
tiens ça serait sympa pour pouvoir
d'achat des consommateurs qui on change
un peu les équations de maxwell à la
peine d'essayer
et bien en ce qui concerne l'énergie
vous avez quelques loi pareille qui
s'applique à nous et qu'on ne peut pas
changer
alors c'est pas pour autant qu'on
n'essaye pas de l'échangé de temps en
temps implicitement par des votes à
l'assemblée nationale mais quand même il
vaut mieux les connaître
donc je voulais dit l'énergie c'est ce
qui compte ici la transformation de
l'environnement
la première loi cardinal qui est très
simple à garder en mémoire en ce qui
concerne l'énergie que vous connaissez
tous par coeur évidemment c'est le
premier principe de la thermodynamique
ou loi de conservation de l'énergie hors
la loi de conservation de l'énergie
appliqués aux hommes
elle a une conséquence qui est
simplissime c'est que les hommes ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre que
d'extraire de l'environnement une
énergie qui existe déjà et s'en servir à
leur profit c'est tout ce que les hommes
sont capables de faire
si les hommes étaient capables de faire
de faire apparaître en leur sein de
l'énergie sans communiquer avec
l'extérieur ont violerait le premier
principe de la thermo alors je suis sûr
que dans un bon harry potter on arrive à
faire ça mais dans le monde réel c'est
plus difficile
donc toute énergie que nous utilisons
nous devons la trouver dans
l'environnement tout
une énergie qui se trouve dans
l'environnement s'appelle une énergie
primaire dans le jargon des d'énergie
des énergéticiens d'accord donc quand
vous voyez passer quelque part dans les
statistiques que je voudrais être de
regarder le terme énergie primaire
ça veut dire qu'il s'agit de l'énergie
telle qu'on la trouve dans
l'environnement alors historiquement et
pardon il ya un autre terme qui est très
fréquent dans l'énergie on y reviendra
dans quelques cours qui est d'énergie
finale l'énergie finale c'est celle qui
passe le compteur du conservateur finale
alors le consommateur final c'est qui
sait vous quand vous êtes chez vous et
vous avez un compteur de gaz sur un
compteur d'électricité ou que vous avez
une cuve à fuel
c'est très mal il faut le dire à
personne et un compteur sur le camion
qui vous livre le fioul ou bien quand
vous êtes industrielle que vous avez un
conteur parce que vous utilisez du gaz
dans un four à verre voilà donc dès que
vous êtes un consommateur final
particuliers ou industriels et que vous
achetez une énergie qui va vous
permettre de faire fonctionner une
machine
ça s'appelle de l'énergie finale
l'énergie qu'on trouve dans
l'environnement l on l'appelle primaire
et entre les deux vous avez évidemment
le système énergétique alors
historiquement la seule énergie primaire
que les hommes savent utiliser c'est la
nourriture donc un pardon et la chaleur
du soleil il y en a deux j'aurais dû
mettre la chaleur du soleil aussi donc
historiquement le seul convertisseur que
les hommes ont à leur disposition ses
oems ce que pour utiliser de l'énergie
faut un convertisseur faut rentrer ça
dans quelque chose qui va en faire
qui va la transformer donc le seul
convertisseur que les hommes possèdent
ces eux mêmes
donc ils mangent ils se chauffent au
soleil et de ces énergies qu'ils
absorbent ou qu'ils ingèrent ils
ressortent de la chaleur beaucoup du
travail un peu et puis après au cours du
temps on a commencéà après à être
capable de domestiquer d'autres
convertisseur alors à part le bois
convertisseur très rustique
on s'est mis à domestiquer toutes les
énergies renouvelables possible alors
les énergies renouvelables ça inclut à
l'époque d'autres organismes vivants
parce que c'est tout à fait
renouvelables
les animaux de trait c'est parfaitement
renouvelables ça mange de l'herbe
parfaitement renouvelables et donc ça
vous fournit de l'énergie parfaitement
renouvelables on a également domestique
et le vent et l'eau au travers des
moulins l'europe antique était couverte
de boulin à eau puis avant et donc il
faut bien voir que les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas l'avenir c'est
le passé alors pas au sens où il n'y a
rien à en attendre à l'avenir
je veux dire c'est que les énergies
renouvelables c'était notre quotidien il
ya quelques siècles donc un monde 100%
vénère je sais très bien à quoi ça
ressemble j'ai au moins un point
d'échantillonnage c'est le monde ya
trois siècles
je suis là il est 100% aux nerfs ça
marche très bien donc un monde avec 1
milliard de bons à homme sur terre
trente ans d'espérance 40 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance et les
deux tiers de la population dans les
champs ça je sais que ça marche en 100%
vénère ya aucun problème puisque on l'a
fait une fois
évidemment le débat aujourd'hui c'est
est ce qu'on arrive à faire la
civilisation avec les ingénieurs à mines
paristech et toutes les machines qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui avec 100 % venaient
alors on y reviendra plus tard
et puis il ya deux siècles il ya
quelques ingénieurs géniaux et quelques
physicien géniaux qui ont dit on
pourrait servir d'autres convertisseur
de convertisseur qui sont eux non
renouvelable en l'occurrence qui sont
les machines fait de métal et on va leur
donner à manger une énergie qu'on ne
sait pas encore utilisé à large échelle
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle les
combustibles fossiles
donc là je vous résume en une planche ce
qui a été l'histoire énergétique des
hommes
d'abord le convertisseur seydoux ensuite
c'est d'autres organismes vivants il ya
eu les esclaves dedans aussi
ensuite les énergies renouvelables et in
fine et des machines en métal avec les
combustibles fossiles et donc ce que je
suis en train de vous dire également
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
essentiel c'est que en fait on ne
consomme pas de l'énergie à part ce que
vous mangez donc quand vous voyez
quelque part consommation d'énergie
c'est un terme impropre
parce que sauf erreur de ma part et je
ne pense pas que vous ayez jamais vu du
pétrole
s'il y en a un qui a déjà fait ça ici
qu'ils me disent mais normalement non je
ne pense pas que vous ayez jamais mangé
du charbon ans celui qui sert pour les
flatulences et vous avez pas respirer du
gaz en tout cas pas du méthane
celui qui donne la voix de mickey
peut-être donc nous ne consommons pas
l'énergie avec notre propre organisme
en fait quand on dit qu'on consomme de
l'énergie c'est un terme impropre mais
c'est un terme impropre qui induit une
illusion d'optique est extrêmement forte
consommer de l'énergie en fait c'est
domestique est une machine donc partout
où vous allez voir consommation
d'énergie y compris dans les planches
parce que tu en entends j'utilise ce
raccourci même si j'essaye de ne pas
barret et vous remplacez par utilisation
de machines et partout où vous voyez que
on consomme de plus en plus d'énergie
vous barrez et vous remplacez par nous
utilisons de plus en plus de machines
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre et en
fait la quantité croissante d'énergie
que nous utilisons ça n'est rien d'autre
que la manière d'augmenter à due
proportion les normes exosquelette
mécanique que nous avons créée à notre
profit c'est ça l'énergie est ce monde
de machines c'est le monde dans lequel
vous vivez
alors sauf erreur de ma part aussi et la
morale et la température font que vous
venez d'en se classe à billets si vous
êtes habillé c'est que vous avez enfilé
un vêtement un moment ou un autre
alors on file un vêtement s'apprend très
exactement même si vous êtes extrêmement
maladroit quelques secondes dans noir
mal réveillé après l'ingestion de
substance que je ne nommerai pas
peut-être quelques dizaines de secondes
mais j'avais beaucoup plus quelques
secondes et bien en quelques secondes
vous avez mobilisé à votre profit des
milliers de machines sans vous en êtes
rendu compte mais vous avez mobilisé à
votre profit des milliers de machine
vous avez commencé par mobilisés à votre
profit toutes ces machines agricoles si
vous avez un vêtement en textile nat
dits naturels du coton du lin etc
vous avez commencé par mobilisés à votre
profit toutes les machines agricoles qui
ont semer récolter et éventuellement
traiter le coton vous avez si vous
utilisez une fibre textile synthétique
donc tout ce qui est poli machin
chouette nylon et c'est tout ça ça vient
du pétrole donc si vous enfilez un sous
vêtement qui comporte des fibres
synthétiques ou un tee shirt qui
comporte des fibres synthétiques et bien
vous avez enfilé à bout de plates formes
pétrolières plus un bout de vapocraqueur
plus à vous de raffineries
ces petites bêtes 1 milliard pièce là
que vous voyez sur cette image si vous
avez autre chose qu'un tissu écru
il a été temps il a donc fallu fabriquer
les teintures dont vous avez de
l'industrie chimique qui a fonctionné en
amont puis vous avez des machines qui
ont pardon il a fallu tisser les fibres
excusez moi d'abord je commence par le
donc ça c'est à nouveau des machines
mécaniques
il a fallu teindre donc ça c'est de
l'industrie chimique il a fallu
transporter parce qu'évidemment c'est
pas à l'endroit où vous faites pousser
le coton que vous le fais
vous le tice et que vous le traîniez etc
donc vous avez des machines qui sont
intervenus à tous les toutes les étapes
intermédiaires de la chaîne qui
s'appelle des camions des trains des
avions
il a fallu fabriquer des boîtes dans
lesquelles on installe les raffineries
dans lesquels on installe les usines
chimiques etc
donc vous avez également ces machines là
qui sont entrés en action
il a fallu que des centrales électriques
alimente une partie du processus donc
ces machines là également sont rentrés
en action
bref un truc totalement anodin on fait
comme on respire qui s'appelle enfilé un
vêtement
eh bien vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte mais il ya une armée de machines
qui ont travaillé pour vous rien qu'avec
ce geste tout simple
alors après vous êtes habillé ceux qui
ont une hygiène correct vont se laver
les dents fin après le petit déjeuner à
nouveau c'est pareil se laver les dents
c'est quelque chose où quoi ça vous
prend à les trois minutes si vous suivez
les conseils du médecin une minute si
vous êtes pressés vous avez de nouveau
utilisé des quantités considérables de
machines simplement pour faire ce geste
vous avez ici une photo d'une usine
chimique qui lie à dans le nord de la
france qui appartient au groupe familial
roquettes et qui a fabriqué un sucre
qu'on trouve dans le dentifrice qui
s'appelle du sorbitol alors vous savez
que le sucre sadok décarie donc si on
met dans le dentifrice du sud qui donne
des caries c'est quand même un peu
ballot donc il se trouve que le sucre
qu'on veut dans le dentifrice pour qu'il
ait un goût un peu sympathique est un
sucre qui donne pas de caries
c'est une molécule qui différentes et en
fait c'est une des quelques centaines de
molécules que vous allez sortir d'une
usine qui s'appelle une amidonnerie dans
lesquels dans laquelle vous rentrez un
train complet de wagons chargés de maïs
tous les jours et vous en ressortez des
centaines de produits chimiques
différents et sur site il ya quelques
milliers de personnes qui travaillent
sur une musique qui tourne très vite
c'est une des plus grosses usines
chimiques de france ensuite vous avez
votre tube qui est en plastique ou en
ont maintenant il est tellement de tubes
en métal donc en plastique à nouveau
plateforme pétrolière raffinerie
vapocraqueur
et c'est votre tube en plastique il
apparaît pas par l'opération du
saint-esprit à partir du plastique donc
il faut un extrudeur que vous voyez ici
vous vous lavez les deux les dents
devant une glace parce que sinon vous
faites des tâches partout donc il a
fallu faire la glace ici vous avez un
train float qui fait la glace à nouveau
vous avez besoin des boîtes des camions
etc
et puis vous vous laver les dents avec
de l'eau purifiée et voilà par exemple
un appareil à purifier l'eau donc à
nouveau une armée de machines qui ont
travaillé pour un geste du quotidien qui
s'appelle se laver les dents
bon j'en viens à l'objet le plus
important de votre vie votre téléphone
et bien c'est pareil quand vous passez
un coup de fil vous avez mobilisé à
votre profit une armée de machines il a
fallu fabriquer des plastiques pour le
téléphone fabriqué de l'eau purifiée
donc vous avez déjà c'est tout ce que je
veux il faut fabriquer de l'acier pour
les supports d'antenne vous avez 40
métaux différents dans un smartphone 40
certains présents à des programmes des
concentrations extrêmement faible et
plusieurs dizaines
donc c'est autant d'activités minières à
droite et à gauche donc autant d'engins
de mines etc dans un réseau télécom qui
permet de faire fonctionner smartphone
parce que si vous êtes le seul à avoir
un smartphone et que les autres n'ont
pas ça sert pas à grand chose enfin s'il
a joué les chenilles mais sinon faut
pouvoir communiquer avec les autres donc
fois un réseau voilà par exemple un
engin à passer des câbles pour faire le
réseau etc etc donc passé un coup de fil
c'est aussi quelque chose qui va
mobiliser des milliers de machines pour
toutes les étapes intermédiaires de
construction et de fonctionnement du
dispositif
donc je le redis aujourd'hui nous vivons
dans un monde de machines et toutes ces
machines sans exception utilisent de
l'énergie tout et vous comprenez bien
pour renverser le raisonnement que je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure sur ces 3
% donc ça n'a pas d'importance que si
vous privez instantanément le monde
d'énergie c'est pas 3% du pib que vous
allez perdre
est assez simple à comprendre 1 vous
n'avez plus un transport qui fonctionne
vous n'avez plus de banques plus de
réseaux d'eau plus d'hôpitaux plus de
transport quel qu'il soit parce que vous
que d'énergie d'accord donc vous mourrez
de faim bourré de froid et vous vous
entretuer en gros c'est ça qui se passe
si demain matin instantanément ont pris
le monde d'énergie donc la totalité du
monde moderne en dépend et que ça coûte
à pour cent mille 100 % de ce que vous
gagnez c'est pas tellement le sujet
enfin c'est un sujet mais c'est loin
d'être le seul sujet à partir de
maintenant on va rentrer dans un certain
nombre d'éléments quantitatif alors
quand on compte l'énergie
vous savez que quand on vous donne un
exercice pour rentrer aux mines en
général l'unité quand vous autorisez la
seule sait le joule moi je vais très peu
m'en servir parce que si je rapporte cij
exprimé en joules les grandeurs qu'on va
aborder à partir de maintenant il y
aurait tellement de zéro sur la slide
que vous prendriez trop de temps à le
regarder donc souvent on va utiliser des
énergies qui sont un peu différentes que
les joules parce que ça permet d'avoir
d'éviter les giga et les mégas et ça
permet d'avoir des choses plus plus
petit alors déjà la première manière
qu'on a de supprimer 6 0 aux geôles
s'est passé au kilowattheure et le
kilowattheure a un avantage c'est que
c'est ça qui figure sur les factures
même si l'énergie n'est pas qu'une
facture ça permet également de se
rapprocher de choses qui sont plus
familières dans l'est dans les
discussions du quotidien un français
aujourd'hui utilisent tous usages
confondus importations comprises
c'est à dire y compris l'énergie qui a
été utilisée hors de france pour faire
fonctionner les machines qui alimente sa
consommation en france parce qu'un
exemple pour reprendre votre smartphone
de tout à l'heure il est made in
ailleurs en totalité eh bien ça se
balade aux alentours de 60 mille
kilowattheures par an en ce qui concerne
les énergéticiens ils ont une unité
qu'ils aiment bien également qui leur
permet encore de gagner 4 0 qui la tonne
équivalent pétrole par la tonne
équivalent pétrole à une définition très
simple c'est l'équivalent de l'énergie
libérée par la combustion d'une tonne de
pétrole alors une tonne de pétrole n'a
pas toujours la même énergie combustion
ça dépend de la nature du pétrole pour
ça qu'on ajoute en général de qualité
moyenne
et ça vaut à peu près 11600
kilowattheure vous aurez de temps en
temps dans l'énergie également des
unités qui sont amenés par les anglo
saxons notamment les américains
et vous savez que les unités américaines
sont assez rarement compatible avec le
système métrique
voilà donc le la tonne équivalent
pétrole s'inscrit dans ce grand ensemble
voilà tu utiliserait un tout petit peu
l'électron volts pas souvent et enfin
j'utiliserai également l'équivalent
esclaves alors l'équivalent esclaves
c'est à peu près 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique et je vais vous
expliquer tout de suite pourquoi qui a
déjà fait ça dans cet amphi
un peu plus les autres senti vide bon ce
qui est déjà montée à pied sur la tour
eiffel
ah ben voilà c'est déjà mieux alors il
va imaginer que pour quelques raisons
qui vous intéressent vous décidiez de
faire dans la journée
6,3 fois l'ascension de la tour eiffel
qui a déjà fait 6,3 fois l'ascension de
la tour eiffel alors c'est bien c'est
pour épater les japonais ou non c'est
pour une autre raison alors si vous
faites 6,3 fois l'ascension de la tour
eiffel dans la journée la tour eiffel
faisant un peu plus de 300 m vous allez
faire de l'ordre de 2000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée si lui il
faudrait 6,6 qui a fait 300 mais je
pense qu'elle fait un peu plus ce
faisant vous allez en général utilisé
vos jambes puisque utilisait ses bras
c'est plus dur et bien l'énergie
mécanique que vous allez restituer avec
un effort de cette nature qui est quand
même pas un effort totalement marginal
pour n'importe qui c e et galen g h1 que
j'utilise donc c'est extrêmement simple
et bien en fait c'est un ridicule demi
kilowattheure sur une journée donc un
homme au travail qui utilise ses jambes
pour alimenter un dispositif mécanique
quel qu'il soit comme charlton heston à
qui [ __ ] dans soleil vert et bien à la
fin de la journée il aura été capable de
restituer de l'ordre de fournir de
l'ordre d'un demi kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
si vous imaginez que cet homme au
travail fourni cet effort un jour sur
deux ce que tu l'autre manière de dire
que vous montez 3 fois la tour eiffel
tous les matins et bien à la fin de
l'année vos jambes ont fourni une
centaine de kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique donc sur une année de travail
la carcasse d'un homme raisonnablement
entraînées et capables de fournir de
l'ordre d'une centaine de kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique s'il utilise ses
jambes si vous utilisez vos bras et soit
dit en passant un peu le dos également
et une pelle c'est plus difficile à
mains nues et que vous des quais ses six
mètres cubes de terre c'est à dire à peu
près 15 tonnes de terre dans une journée
et bien outre des ampoules vous aurait
fourni 0,05 kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique c'est à dire que vous êtes
encore dix fois plus ridicule entre
guillemets que la personne qui a monté
trois fois la tour eiffel avec ses
jambes donc une paire de bras au travail
dans la journée c'est 0,05 kilowattheure
une paire de bras au travail sur l'année
c'est une dizaine de kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique si vous faites
brûler un litre d'essence qui coûte le
prix scandaleusement élevés de 20 euros
60 ce qui justifie que l'on trouve que
c'est trop cher et bien vous allez
obtenir 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
thermique et si vous voulez avoir une
comparaison stricte évidemment il faut
faire passer ça dans une machine qui va
convertir cette énergie thermique en
éclats en énergie mécanique et même avec
les meilleurs ingénieurs des mondes du
monde pardon pour faire des voitures qui
parait-il sort d'ici et bien vous allez
obtenir 2 à 4 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique pas plus ça dépend pas de
l'ingénieur les deux à quatre ça dépend
en fait de la manière dont la voiture
fonctionne si elle est proche de son
rendement optimal ou pas eh bien
donc si elle est à deux c'est de la
faute du conducteur c'est pas la vôtre
donc vous allez obtenir 2 à 4 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique c'est à dire
que dans un seul litre d'essence dont on
verra dans pas longtemps que les
français en consomment encore entre
guillemets des pas loin de militants eh
bien vous avez le même contenu en
travail la même capacité à changer
d'environnement que dans 10 à 100 jours
de travail de force d'un être humain
dont je vous le redis autrement quand
vous utilisez une machine qui consomme
un litre d'essence
vous êtes capable de modifier
l'environnement c'est-à-dire de fournir
du travail au même niveau que 10 à 100
êtres humains qui utiliserait soient
leurs jambes soient leurs bras qui va si
vous vous rendez compte du différentiel
que vous avez entre l'énergie qu'on
utilise via la machine et notre propre
corps
si on convertit tout ça en argent une
autre façon de dire la même chose c'est
que le kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique si je paye un nouveau travail
pour le fournir je vais le payer de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
d'euros alors qu'en face la machine au
travail me fournit le même service pour
un coût marginal j'ai pas mis la machine
là dedans de l'ordre de quelques
dizaines de centimes donc quand je passe
de l'homme au travail à la machine à
travers la machine au travail hors coût
de la machine
eh bien j'ai divisé le coup d'une
transformation unitaire de
l'environnement par un facteur de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
la raison pour laquelle on mécanise tout
ce qu'on peut dans le monde économique
elle est là donc dès que vous pouvez
remplacer un garçon des tâches par un
robot
fait dès que vous pouvez remplacer un
ouvrier monteur sur une chaîne par un
robot vous le faites dès que vous pouvez
mécanisée n'importe quoi un agriculteur
le remplacer par un tracteur vous allez
toujours toujours toujours le faire à
cause de cette différence absolument
considérable de prix entre le travail
humain et l'énergie c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a toujours cherché depuis
qu'on a des machines qu'ils utilisent
des machines efficace à remplacer les
hommes par des machines
ça va même jouer pour le remplacement
des esclaves si vous prenez un esclave
ce qui est en général n'est pas une
vocation de jeunesse et bien cet esclave
pour le faire travailler vous allez
devoir aller le chercher contre sa
volonté
faut payer de l'argent je vous rappelle
qu'il ya eu une époque où il y avait une
traite des esclaves qui était un
business tout à fait immorales au regard
des critères actuels mais en attendant
c'était quand même fait pour des raisons
économiques
il faut l'empêcher de votre idée il faut
l'empêcher de fiche le camp il faut le
nourrir etc
et quand vous regardez ce que ça coûte
d'obtenir le travail d'un esclave et
bien vous vous rendez compte que même ça
ça va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois plus
cher que la machine qui n'a rien contre
sa condition de machines qui ne
cherchent pas à [ __ ] le camp et qui ne
se met pas en grève et qui travaille h
24 donc la raison pour laquelle
l'esclavagisme a disparu dans les
sociétés qui ont eu accès à l'énergie
c'est pas parce qu'on est devenu
soudainement parce qu'on a changé de
code génétique dont je vais faire une
petite incursion dans le cours auquel
vous n'êtes pas allé pour certains
d'entre vous c'est pas parce que notre
code génétique à changer de code
génétique est très exactement le même
que celui qu'avait nos ancêtres il ya
deux ou trois siècles
simplement il n'y a plus d'incitations à
faire des choses que nous faisions à
l'époque parce qu'on va trouver beaucoup
mieux et beaucoup moins enquiquinant
pour faire la même chose donc ce qui a
libéré les esclaves c'est le pétrole en
euros
le à ce stade il ya quelques premières
conclusions
donc je vous propose donc que je vous
rappelle donc je vous rappelle que
d'utiliser de l'énergie suppose que
l'énergie existe déjà dans
l'environnement donc quand dans un débat
vous voyez des gens qui vous disent on
pourrait utiliser l'hydrogène de
l'hydrogène dans l'environnement il ya
un an dont il y en a beaucoup s'appelle
le soleil pas très commode d'aller le
chercher le reste il est partout sous
forme liées dans le dos il y en a plein
vous en avez plein dans la vie et c'est
partout il est sous forme liés donc il
n'est pas disponible en tant que source
d'énergie
la molécule est disponible l'énergie non
il faut casser les liaisons donc par
exemple l'électrolysé de l'eau et pour
ça vous avez besoin de plus d'énergie
que l'énergie que vous récupérez dans la
combustion d'hydrogène donc l'hydrogène
n'est pas une source d'énergie primaire
quand on vous dit on pourrait utiliser
la pile à combustible
bah ouais enfin c'est un moteur la pile
à combustible ce n'est pas une source
d'énergie donc ce qu on doit comparer
aux énergies primaires qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui c'est d'autre énergie
primaire c'est à dire des choses qu'on
peut trouver dans l'environnement et qui
sont utilisables tels que dans
l'environnement
le reste n'est pas accessible le comme
l'énergie quantifie la transformation
vous n'avez pas d'énergie verte ou doit
10 en passant pas d'énergie rose
pas plus que d'énergie noire en fait
choisir une énergie c'est choisir un
type de transformation et c'est choisir
des avantages et des contreparties toute
énergie est sale si vous l'amener à un
niveau suffisant d'utilisation n'importe
laquelle
le jour où vous couvrez la totalité de
la terre la planète de panneaux
photovoltaïques ce ssd propre donc une
énergie propre
en général quand vous regardez les
chiffres vous vous rendez compte que
c'est une énergie qui est utilisé en
quantités suffisamment minimes pour que
ces inconvénients le souhaite également
en général c'est ça une énergie propre
dès que l'énergie commence à être
utilisés en quantité massive
quel que soit le mode d'extraction de
l'environnement il ya des inconvénients
et choisir une énergie c'est arbitrer
entre les inconvénients dont on a envie
et ce dont on n'a pas envie c'est ça le
sait ça le sujet
quelque chose qui est absolument
essentiel je vais y revenir plusieurs
fois pendant cette première ce premier
module de cours
c'est que l'énergie l'énergie
je parle pas de ceux qui permet de
l'extraire de l'environnement l'énergie
est gratuite
alors vous savez que vous avez enfin
vous avez tous entendu le vent c'est
gratuit le soleil c'est gratuit donc ya
pas de raison de pas s'en servir
de fait le vent et le soleil sont
gratuits personne dans cette salle n'a
payé le moindre centime pour que le
soleil existe pour que le vent existe
mais personne dans cette salle non plus
n'a payé le moindre centime pour que le
pétrole existe le pétrole est gratuit ce
qui est payant c'est le consentement à
s'en défaire de la personne qui a la
chance d'être assise dessus ça c'est
payant et ce qui est payant c'est le
travail des quelques-uns d'entre vous
qui iront chez total c'est très mal me
dites à personne pour aller faire des
trous dans la terre et fait ressortir le
pétrole ça c'est payant le pétrole est
gratuit c'est gratuit
donc quand on paye l'énergie tout ce
qu'on paye c'est du travail humain et
des rentes du maine pour accéder à une
énergie qui elle est gratuite
on ne paye que des hommes et du reste
l'argent ne sert à payer que des hommes
vous n'avez jamais vu la nature envoyé
une facture à qui que ce soit donc on ne
paye que des hommes comme l'énergie
c'est de la physique
et comme ce que vous payez ça n'est pas
l'énergie elle même mais le travail
qu'il faut consacrer à son extraction de
l'environnement le prix d'une énergie ne
dépend pas de l'abondance de l'énergie
parce qu'on pourrait se dire si
l'énergie est très abondante du coup
elle est encore plus gratuite que les
autres en fait c'est pas ça qui compte
si une énergie est très abondante elle
peut quand même être très difficile à
extraire de l'environnement savez il ya
une énergie qui est totalement
surabondante dans l'univers c'est le
rayonnement à 3 degrés kelvin dans le
vide ça je peux vous dire vous en ferez
jamais rien et pourtant il ya des
quantités absolument considérable donc
le fait qu'il y ait des quantités
absolument considérable d'énergie ça ne
nous dit rien sur la facilité à
l'extraire pour s'en servir à notre
profit ce qui va compter pour le coût de
l'énergie c'est à dire la facilité qu'il
y a à l'extraire et à l'utiliser à notre
profit c'est le fait que la source
d'énergie préexistantes dans
l'environnement soit déjà très concentré
et avec peu de barrières nous séparant
de l'accès à cette source
et alors l'archétype de ce truc là c'est
le pétrole le pétrole c'est hyper
concentré c'est l'énergie à part le
nucléaire mais l'énergie nucléaire est
plus compliqué à utiliser
c'est hyper concentré et les barrières
qui nous sépare de son accès sont pas
très dur à franchir
historiquement monsieur drac il est allé
faire trois trous à titusville et le
pétrole jaillit d'accord c'est pas très
compliqué historiquement de faire sortir
du pétrole plus une énergie est séparé
de doux par des grandes barrières et
plus elle est diffuse plus elle coûtera
cher à extraire de l'environnement c'est
juste de la physique
et alors je vais vous le montrer avec
une petite comparaison rapide
imaginons que je prenne le volume d'air
de cette salle qui n'est pas très très
loin en ordre de grandeur de représenter
un cube de 10 mètres de côté imaginons
que je le fasse souffler à 80 km heure
ce qui représente au choix pour les
méridionaux un bon mistral ou pour les
marins à 45 devant et je fais passer ça
dans une éolienne
si je fais passer dans une éolienne se
vend ça va me mettre mon d'éoliennes en
actions est de fournir de l'électricité
cette électricité est une énergie je
peux raconter et bien la quantité
d'électricité que je récupère avec mille
mètres cube d'air à 80 kilomètres heure
qui passe dans les éoliennes c'est la
même que la quantité d'énergie que je
récupère en faisant brûler 3000 litres
de pétrole 3 pas 3 tonnes pas 3 litres
pas 30 litres 3 millilitres 3
tout-petits millilitres en ce qui
concerne la quantité de travail humain
investir à votre avis est-ce que c'est
plus simple d'aller donner d'aller faire
un trou dans le désert saoudien est de
faire sortir trois billes de pétrole ou
est-ce que c'est plus simple de
construire une éolienne d'attendre que
le vent souffle et de récupérer
l'électricité qui en sort
et bien la réponse est dans les prix
puisque l'argent ne paye que les hommes
si vous utilisez une éolienne vous allez
en europe
payez votre kilowattheures d'électricité
de 6 à 8 centimes en sortie d'éoliennes
est à ce prix là il ya court quand il ya
du vent il ya quand ya pas de vent d'une
vidéo projecteurs fonctionnent pas bon
alors je peux y aller un peu fort il ya
pas de micros que c'est pas grave je
peux faire avec les mains sans vie au
premier par contre pour tous ceux
d'entre vous qui sont venus en métro n'y
a pas de métro non plus c'est un peu
plus enquiquinant il n'ya pas non plus
de soirée ce soir si le vent ne souffle
pas ça ça commence à devenir vraiment
vraiment qu'ils n'en il n'y a pas de
réveil demain matin si les marches à
l'électricité
le frigo on peut parfois dire les bières
en face à une catastrophe
donc s'il n'y a pas de vent le système
s'arrête si vous voulez que le système
s'arrête pas on tient pas devant vous
devez rajouter le coût du stockage est
alors à ce moment vous multipliez en
gros par trois ans des fois par six donc
l'ordre de grandeur du kilowattheure
stockée avec du vent ces quelques
dizaines de centimes en face de ça
l'ordre de grandeur du coût du
kilowattheure déjà stocké puisque quand
vous sortez votre pétrole du sol c'est
déjà un stock à ce moment là vous pouvez
déjà vous en servir aujourd'hui demain
après-demain la semaine prochaine ou à 3
heures du matin exactement comme ça vous
chante hé bien ce kilowattheure de
pétrole déjà stocké sortie du désert
saoudien il vaut 0 3 centime donc entre
le coût d'un kilowattheure extrait du
vent sources diffuses c'est pas dense
l'air 1,2 kg par mètre cube
c'est vraiment pas dense et le coût du
kilowattheure sortie la plus de pétrole
saoudien
eh bien vous avez un facteur de l'ordre
d'une centaine sur le coût de mise à
disposition d'un kilowattheure stocker
est encore là l'éolienne vous l'avait
elle même fabriquée avec du pétrole
le système n'est pas bouclé c'est à dire
que pour fabriquer l'éolienne vous avez
bénéficié d'un système industriel très
performant qui vous a fait l'extraction
du cuivre de la mise
l'extraction de la bauxite de la mine
l'extraction du minerai de fer de la
mine
la métallurgie avons l'assemblage de
tout ce bastringue le transport le plot
en béton pour l'ériger etc
tout ça a été fait avec des combustibles
fossiles si vous deviez faire tout ça
avec d'autres éoliennes s'est pas
complètement sûr que le prix de l'éolien
serait toujours de 6 à 8 centimes le
kilowattheure on peut prendre les paris
mon pari c'est que ça vaudrait un peu
plus cher donc même en faisant
l'éolienne avec des combustibles
fossiles et bien vous vous rendez compte
que vous avez un facteur de quelques
dizaines à une centaine entre eux un
kilowattheure sortie du vent et un
kilowattheure sortie d'un puits de
pétrole facile et ça c'est irrémédiable
parce que c'est de la physique
donc c'est pour cette raison que
historiquement nous ne sommes pas passés
les combustibles fossiles aux énergies
renouvelables mais nous avons fait
l'exact inverse
il ya deux siècles la marine était 100%
renouvelable et du reste comme le vent
soufflait pas tout
il fallait embarquer des citrons pour
être sûr que les marins à papa de
scorbut on s'est dit que quand même pour
vous amener le t-shirt chez zara
rapidement parce que le t-shirt n'est
pas fabriqué en france c'est quand même
vachement mieux d'avoir une marine 100%
fossiles c'est beaucoup plus efficace ça
va beaucoup plus vite
nous avions un système de transport 100%
renouvelable
il ya quelques siècles et on s'est dit
que quand même pour alimenter l'école
des mines pour le repas du midi c'est
pas terrible
il vaut beaucoup mieux avoir des
transports 100% fossiles ça marche mieux
on avait une agriculture 100%
renouvelable et on s'est dit quand même
pour avoir une agriculture très
productives et que les enfants des
paysans puissent aller faire des études
ce pas terrible il vaut beaucoup mieux
avoir une agriculture 100% fossiles on
avait des travaux publics 100%
renouvelable
c'est avec ça que les romains ont
construit les voies romaines c'était pas
très rapide pour faire un million de
kilomètres de routes en france c'est
quand même beaucoup plus rapide
d'utiliser demain comme ça ça va
beaucoup plus vite
nous avions une industrie de la
construction 100 % renouvelable un
siècle pour faire notre dame
alors maintenant ça va aller un peu plus
vite pour refaire la toiture mais le
voilà et probablement quelques siècles
pour faire les pyramides c'était pas
très efficace pour faire la tour d2 à la
défense c'est beaucoup mieux d'utiliser
des combustibles fossiles ça va beaucoup
plus vite
nous avions une industrie 100%
renouvelable à nouveau c'était pas très
efficace pour faire tous les objets et
que vous avez sur vous un bac où ça
marche pas bien
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux d'avoir
une industrie 100% fossiles et nous
avions des séchoirs à luzerne 100%
renouvelable
c'est à dire le soleil et c'est quand
même pas très efficace il vaut beaucoup
mieux avoir des séchoirs à luzerne qui
marche au gaz ça va plus vite
donc ça fait deux siècles précisément
parce que les caractéristiques physiques
des énergies fossiles sont supérieurs
aux caractéristiques physiques des
énergies renouvelables que l'homme qui
est un animal accumulatif a passé son
temps à passer des énergies
renouvelables aux énergies fossiles pour
être capable d'accumuler plus vite
c'est exactement pour ça qu'on a fait ce
chemin là et donc quand vous voyez ça
vous vous dites que de faire le chemin
inverse comme ça l'a simplement parce
que la promesse politique c'est qu'on va
y arriver sans qu'on touche au niveau de
vie des gens
rien qu'en voyant sarah vous vous dites
ah ah en étant totalement sûr
est-ce que je signe avec toutes mes
économies plus celle de mes parents plus
c'est l'avenir de m
en par an sur le fait que ça va marcher
incidemment quand vous avez un doute sur
quelque chose
c'est une très bonne question à vous
poser c'est à dire est ce que je serais
d'accord pour parier la totalité des
économies de mes parents sur ce que je
suis en train d'affirmer voit la fin de
la parenthèse
si vous avez un tout petit doute sur le
fait que la réponse soit pas oui c'est
que en gros vous n'êtes pas totalement
convaincu par l'argument ou parce qu'on
est en train de vous raconter
donc les énergies renouvelables on
connaît très très bien
c'est le monde dont l'humanité sort
j'insiste donc tu pas en train de dire
qu'il faut pas y retourner
je suis juste en train de vous préparer
à la conclusion qui est qu on y
retournera sûrement pas à consommation
constante surprend pas avec 7 milliards
de bons hommes sur terre donc voilà nos
convertisseurs des temps anciens alors
c'était tout à fait immoral c'était pas
du tout efficace pas du tout efficace
par contre c'était tout à fait
renouvelables et nous sommes passés
maintenant à des convertisseurs des
temps modernes qui sont beaucoup plus
efficaces
à n'en point douter alors si je parle
pas énergie mais que je parle puissance
maintenant bien vous voyez un homme au
travail dont je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure en une journée de labeur il peut
faire entre 0 05 et 0 5 kilowatt heure
si vous rapportez ça à 5 heures de
travail en fait ces dix mais peu importe
vous voyez que ça veut dire que sa
puissance moyenne sur cette durée se
baladent quelque part entre 10 et 100
watts je prends un tracteur un tracteur
ordinaire aujourd'hui à une puissance de
quelques dizaines de kilowatts un
tracteur ça a la même puissance soit dit
en passant que un engin de chantier qui
fait une centaines de kilowatts si un
jour vous êtes un peu curieux la
prochaine fois que vous passez à côté
d'un chantier sur tous les engins de
chantier vous avez une petite plaque qui
vous donne la puissance du moteur qui
est planqué quelque part ou sous la
partie pivotante
enfin voilà c'est pas très compliqué a
localisé à les regarder par curiosité
vous verrez la puissance de l'engin
quelques dizaines de kilomètres jusqu'à
100 kilowatts pour une grosse pelle si
vous substituer des jambes quelques
centaines si vous substituer des bras
quelques milliers donc les deux engins
que vous avez là sont capables pour le
tracteur de substituer quelques
centaines de paires de jambes ou
quelques dizaines d'années
très et pour l'engin de travaux publics
où l'engin de construction quelques
milliers de paires de bras
c'est grâce à ça qu'on a pu augmenter la
productivité d'un agriculteur par
quelques centaines
parce que il n'y a pas poussé des
centaines de bras et des centaines de
jambes comme shiva l'agriculteur on l'a
simplement doté d'un exosquelette et
c'est grâce à ça que aujourd'hui on peut
construire une maison ça plus tout un
tas d'autres machines des cimenteries
des camions etc
on peut aujourd'hui construire une
maison pour le coup de quelques années
de salaire chose qui était totalement
impensable pour un habitant des temps
anciens
jusqu'à il ya deux ou trois siècles
c'était juste impensable que quelqu'un
se fasse construire sa maison pour
quelques années de salaire ça n'existait
pas un camion [ __ ] comme quelques
milliers de fois les jambes du
conducteur un avion grâce au jeune et
beau pilotes bien payés [ __ ] comme un
million de fois les jambes du pilote
celui d'aeroflot t'as pas dû pédaler
assez fort un laminoir industriel martel
écrase l'acier comme toute l'île de
france à qui j'aurais donné un marteau
donc vous voyez rien que pour remplacer
le laminoir de fos-sur-mer si on n'avait
pas d'énergie vous seriez pas en train
d'écouter ce cours en ce moment entre
vous sans faute aurait peut-être mieux
vous seriez avec un marteau en train de
taper sur des tôles rien que pour
remplacer de l'habit noir de fos-sur-mer
toute l'ile-de-france avec un marteau en
train de marteler toute la journée
voilà un autre auxiliaire de
l'agriculture qui a économisé quelques
millions de paires de bras ça s'appelle
un vapocraqueur
et c'est quelque chose qui sert à vous
préparer la chimie org
à ce stade on est d'accord sur le fait
que l'énergie quantifie la
transformation sur le fait que pour
utiliser de l'énergie en fait vous avez
besoin d'un convertisseur sur le fait
que l'essentiel des convertisseurs que
nous utilisons aujourd'hui ne sont plus
nos propres corps mais sont des machines
et maintenant je vais vous quantifier le
parc de machines et la manière dont ils
se décomposent par individu alors je
dédie historiquement ce qu'on utilisait
c'était surtout des énergies
renouvelables oui si vous avez un
graphique qui démarre en 1860 et qui ne
vous quand ici qu'une des énergies
renouvelables qu'on a utilisées depuis
des temps anciens parce que le vent et
l'eau c'est difficile d'avoir des
statistiques en séries longues je suis
sûr que quelqu'un avait reconstitué ça
mais j'ai pas trouvé
donc là on va déjà commencer par le bois
donc le bois il ya un siècle et demi
l'humanité on utilise l'humanité en
utilise pour alimenter des poils pour se
chauffer pour alimenter des forges et
soit dit en passant lüthi le début de la
métallurgie a été un facteur massif de
déforestation ou un facteur très
important de déforestation en europe et
pour faire fonctionner les premières
machines à vapeur qui commencent à
émerger ici et là à cette époque là un
habitant du monde
un terrien consomme en moyenne 5000
kilowattheure de bois par an alors vous
voyez que par personne depuis cette
époque la quantité de bois utilisés à
diminuer pas au total mais par personne
ça a diminué
c'est la seule énergie en gros qui est
suivi cette évolution
après les hommes se sont mis à utiliser
du charbon alors une partie du charbon a
substitué le bois par exemple en europe
on a commencé à utiliser du charbon
avant on utilisait du charbon de bois et
puis on s'est mis à utiliser du charbon
dit de terre les deux s'appelait du
charbon pour faire fonctionner les
forges
puis après pour faire fonctionner les
machines à vapeur et vous voyez que la
quantité de charbon utilisé par
personnes dans le monde qui étaient
extrêmement faibles
il ya un siècle et demi se monte
aujourd'hui à peu près à 5000 kilowatts
heure par personne et par an ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique également c'est
que la quantité de charbon utilisé par
personne dans le
n'a jamais baissé depuis qu'on a
commencé à utiliser du charbon donc
jamais à aucun moment le charbon n'a été
une énergie du passé pour les hommes
jamais à aucun moment et en faites-vous
aujourd'hui vous utilisez sans le savoir
énormément de charbon à travers tout ce
qui est importée de pays où c'est made
in charbon à commencer par la chine a
donc des vous voyez quelque part made in
china
c'est bed-in charbon et ça alimente
directement votre consommation indirects
évidemment de charme
les deux tiers du charbon qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui sur terre sert en fait à une
machine intermédiaire du système
énergétique qui s'appelle la centrale
électrique donc les deux tiers du
charbon extrait sur terre alimente une
centrale électrique dans le reste vous
avez 1 10% en gros qui alimente la
métallurgie alors cdd charbon
particulier très riches en carbone qu'on
appelle des charbons à coke et sinon le
reste sert à faire fonctionner des
réseaux de chaleur des poils du
chauffage urbain et enfin du chauffage
domestique etc
mais les deux tiers c'est les centrales
électriques vous savez qu'en france on a
un grand débat sur nos centrales
nucléaires
retenez que aujourd'hui dans le monde
vous avez entre 30 et 40 fois entre 30
et 40 fois la puissance installée en
centrale à charbon entre 30 et 40 fois
par dont la puissance nucléaire
installée en france en centrale à
charbon en france on a 60 gigawatts de
nucléaire
ça va à peu près de 2000 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon installés dans le
monde on y reviendra au moment du cours
sur le climat mais l'accord de paris ça
vous dit un petit quelque chose
et plus exactement l'objectif des 2
degrés est contenue dans l'accord de
paris suppose par exemple que la
totalité de ses centrales à charbon et
disparu d'ici est ce que vous ayez mon
âge
corps donc trois mètres séparent donc
d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge pas si
loin que ça vous assure eh bien il faut
que la totalité des centrales à charbon
mondiale et disparus dont un petit peu
de jours après les hommes ont utilisé du
pétrole en ce que vous voyez sur ce
graphique de manière absolument
spectaculaire c'est que le pétrole a
jamais remplacer le charbon et pétrole
n'a pas remplacé le charmant
vous voyez que la l'utilisation du
pétrole par personne vient se rajouter
en plus de l'utilisation du charbon par
personne la raison c'est que le pétrole
ne sert pas du tout à ce à quoi sert le
charbon le pétrole c'est d'énergie règne
de la mobilité
parce que le pétrole et l'énergie qui a
le meilleur ratio énergie transportés
par unité de volume d'accord dans un
litre donc un des six mètres cubes
si vous mettez quelque chose qui vous
sert à votre approvisionnement
énergétique
y a rien de mieux que le pétrole c'est
liquide à température ambiante
donc c'est un truc qui se stockent et se
transporte extrêmement facilement et
comme c'est le plus dense par unité de
volume et bien dans les modes de
transport ou vous devez emporter votre
énergie avec vous comme ça vous êtes sûr
de pouvoir aller vous voulez c'est le
pétrole qui a gagné la manche où la main
des modes de transport aujourd'hui 98 %
de ce qui roule volou navigue utilise du
pétrole alors que je vous rappelle que
la première voiture à avoir dépassé les
100 kilomètres heure dans le monde et
est une voiture électrique
je vous rappelle également que le
rendement du moteur électrique est
quatre fois supérieur à trois à quatre
fois supérieur au rendement du moteur à
pétrole
donc c'est pas parce que le moteur à
pétrole est intrinsèquement supérieur
qui l'a supplanté la voiture électrique
dans la compétition qui a eu lieu il ya
un siècle
c'est parce qu'avec l'électricité vous
avez beaucoup plus de mal à emporter
avec vous l'énergie qui vous permet
d'être autonome
c'est ça la région
vous voyez également quelque chose qui
s'est produit avant votre naissance ici
l'arrêt soudain je dis bien soudain de
la quantité de pétrole disponible par
personne sur terre
cet épisode il porte un nom un peu
particulier dans l'histoire de l'énergie
ça s'appelle les chocs pétroliers
j'y reviendrai longuement les chocs
pétroliers tout le monde a gardé en
mémoire que c'est un moment où le prix
est devenue très élevé puis après il est
redevenu très bas et
sujets suivants s'il vous plaît on
oublie en fait on n'oublie pas du tout
c'est le moment où l'approvisionnement
pétrolier croix s'est fortement et où il
s'est arrêté de croître fortement et où
l'approvisionnement pétrolier par
personne croisée fortement et non
seulement il s'est arrêté de croître
mais en suisse est mis à décroître puis
se stabiliser donc les chocs pétroliers
ça correspond pas juste à un épisode de
prix en fait les cuma la surface de la
vague
la caractéristique majeure du choc
pétrolier c'est que c'est l'arrêt un nom
dans l'expansion rapide
c'est ça les chocs pétroliers et on va
venir dans pas longtemps à ce que ça
signifie en termes économiques arrive le
gaz alors le gaz bis repetita n'a pas
remplacer le pétrole
il est venu se rajouter par dessus
arrive
l'hydroélectricité pareil
l'hydroélectricité est venue se rajouter
par dessus arrive le nucléaire venue se
rajouter par dessus et alors maintenant
arrive les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables que vous voyez là et qui
est le truc dont tout le monde parle on
parle plus que de ça
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
vous avez ici rapporté à l'individu ce
que représentent ces nouvelles énergies
renouvelables dans le monde et comme je
suis
malgré les apparences un mec sympa j'ai
pris la convention de conversion la plus
sympathique possible pour les
comptabiliser parce que comme beaucoup
de ces énergies sont des énergies
purement électrique le solaire et
l'éolien et vous avez deux manières de
les comptabiliser de l'énergie
électrique vous avez deux manières de la
comptabilisés dans les bilans
énergétiques comme historiquement
l'essentiel de l'électricité a été
produite avec des bottes thermique c'est
des machines de carnot où les centrales
électriques pour l'essentiel vous brûler
du charbon vous brûler du gaz vous
brûler du pétrole vous faites fissionner
de l'uranium ça vous fait de la chaleur
et avec cette chaleur vous actionner une
turbine
c'est une machine de carnot dans une
machine de carnot vous avez un rendement
maximum à monter de sûreté 1 et souvent
on compte l'électricité en équivalent
primaire c'est à dire on compte
l'énergie thermique qui auraient été
nécessaires pour faire la même quantité
d'électricité pour les modes qui sont
purement électrique l'hydroélectricité
en tête le solaire l'éolien et c'est la
convention que j'ai utilisé pour ce
graphique il n'empêche que vous voyez
que aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup plus
de place dans la pagination du journal
que ça n'en a dans la consommation
effective d'énergie dans le monde et
vous allez voir dans pas longtemps que
non seulement c'est vrai en valeur
absolue mais malheureusement c'est aussi
vrai en dynamique par contre une autre
chose qui est capital quand on voit ce
graphique c'est que vous voyez
aujourd'hui la quantité d'énergie
mobilisés par personne et par an
d'énergie extracorporelle devrait
préciser est de l'ordre de 20 mille
kilowattheure donc un terrien mobilise
en moyenne au travers de l'énorme
exosquelette que constitue le parc de
machines 20000 kilowatts heure par
personne et par an avec la petite
équivalent ce que je vous ai donné tout
à l'heure alors ça c'est de l'énergie
primaire c'est d'énergie thermique donc
en énergie mécanique ça ferait moins
évidemment
par contre là dedans vous allez
remplacer des gens mais vous allez aussi
remplacer des bras alors j'ai fait une
convention à la la la serre de 1 pour 1
et donc je vous dis c'est comme si en
gros chaque terrien avait à sa
disposition
deux cents personnes 200 esclaves qui
posait pour lui en permanence
je vais vous le dire autrement le parc
de machines que nous avons constitué qui
travaillent pour nous à la même force
mécanique que si notre puissance
musculaire était multipliée par deux
sens donc vous êtes je suis nous sommes
devenus superman pour de vrai c'est pas
une vue de l'esprit
sauf qu'au lieu comme popeye de
s'engouffrer une boîte d'épinards et
devenir surpuissant nous on s'engouffre
un baril de pétrole et on devient
surpuissant va pas nous mais notre
exosquelette c'est à dire les machines
je vais vous le redire encore autrement
la production matérielle de l'humanité
aujourd'hui à 7 milliards d'individus
est équivalente en volume à cause des
machines à ce qu'on aurait si nous
n'avions si nous avions 1400 milliards
d'individus et pas de machine c'est
clair évidemment on n'a pas les moyens
de nourrir 1400 milliards d'individus
sur terre
donc en fait grâce à l'énergie et grâce
aux machines
nous avons été capables de développer
une capacité productive qui est sans
commune mesure avec la puissance
musculaire notre organisme et nous
passons de journée à utiliser les
prothèses le rer qui m'amène ici est une
prothèse
prolongement de mes jambes la voiture
que vous utiliserez peut-être et l'avion
encore plus c'est des prothèses cd
prolongement de nos jambes comme en
passant tout passe son temps à utiliser
des prothèses l'essentiel de cette
énergie et fossiles alors pourquoi
fossiles tout simplement parce que c'est
des restes de vie ancienne un fossile
c'est très simple encore une fois ça une
définition c'est un reste de vie
ancienne
on verra ça au prochain concours le
charbon est un reste de vie végétale
fougères qui ont poussé à l'ère du
charbon au carbonifère et le pétrole et
le gaz sont des restes de plancton et de
micro algues qui ont vécu n'importe
quand entre il ya quelques millions
d'années et quelques centaines de
millions d'années donc c'est l'énergie
fossile et de très loin qui domine
l'approvisionnement mondial aujourd'hui
et cette énergie
elle a donc permis de mettre en
mouvement de mettre en mouvement un parc
un exosquelette croissant qui a fait de
chacun d'entre vous et de chacune
d'entre vous ironman pour de vrai donc
nous sommes tous devenus iron man pour
de vrai on n'a pas la petite lumière qui
brille au centre et les machins devant
les yeux là mais c'est exactement ça
donc voilà des petits bouts de votre
costume d'iron man et du mien des
machines à laver des ascenseurs des
aspirateurs détracteurs des tractopelles
des fusées ariane des satellites des
épurateurs dos des laminoirs des
tréfileur etc tout ça c'est un petit
bout de votre costume d'iron man
laissant ce costume d'iron man
vous auriez la vie qu'avait les paysans
français il ya quelques siècles avec 30
ans d'espérance de vie à la naissance
aucune augmentation du revenu entre la
naissance et la mort l'idée que leurs
revenus augmentent avec l'âge c'est un
truc qui est moderne ça ça n'existait
pas dans les temps anciens
et c'est donc ce qui a littéralement
changé la vie de l'humanité c'est
l'énergie et le parc de machines qui
permet de s'en servir
voilà pourquoi le fait que ça ne vas y
que 3% de ce qu'on dépense c'est une
illusion d'optique
c'est au centre de 100 % de ce qui vous
arrive
le 100%
en fait avec la petite conventions
économiques que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que l'énergie
aujourd'hui et le parc de machines qu'il
actionne ses 200 fois la puissance
musculaire des hommes
si la comptabilité était accordée avec
cette réalité physique dans les comptes
des entreprises l'énergie devrait valoir
200 fois plus cher que les choses que
les salaires c'est ça qui devrait se
passer donc votre salaire allant gauche
devrait être angot divisé par un facteur
1000 en gros c'est à peu près ça qu'on
devrait faire si on devait avoir le même
rapport comptable sur les coûts que on a
le rapport physique sur la contribution
à la transformation du monde
je vais vous le dire encore autrement
parce que je vais tenir dans pas
longtemps les hommes aujourd'hui pour la
production de ce nécessaire que pour
piloter des machines pour le reste ils
servent à rien donc l'essentiel des
bouleaux qu'on fait aujourd'hui dans le
monde je vous coupe devra vosges aux
jambes elle vous permet de commander un
ordinateur avec votre cervelle ça marche
encore
ça marche encore
alors cet exosquelette avec son énergie
viendra lui permet donc d'avoir la même
capacité productive alors en moyenne
mondiale ces deux sens le facteur en
moyenne française c'est plutôt six ans
donc le gilet jaune français qui ne s'en
rend pas compte
et c'est ça la vérité politique
indicible vie quand même comme un nabab
il vit comme un nabab ce qu'ils ont
merde c'est que bernard arnault vie
encore plus comme un diable que lui mais
en attendant et il a probablement raison
de le penser mais en attendant il vit
comme un nabab déjà nuit 1 à cause de ça
ces esclaves des temps modernes ou un
autre avantages absolument considérables
par rapport aux énergies renouvelables
des temps anciens c'est qu'il nous
libère toute la surface pour nous parce
que les esclaves énergétique des temps
anciens
donc soit les énergies renouvelables
soient les autres organismes vivants
dont on avait besoin mobiliser du sol un
animal de trait mobilise du sol donc le
sol qui est nécessaire pour nourrir
l'animal de trait n'est plus disponible
pour nourrir des hommes ou un animal de
transport à l'époque
donc on avait notamment dans
l'agriculture besoin de mobiliser une
grande partie des surfaces pour être
capable de cultiver le reste des
surfaces pour les hommes avec les
animaux de trait là les esclaves des
temps modernes
ils mangent du sous sol donc il nous
laisse la totalité de l'espace
disponible pour nous et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles quand on parle
de revenir aux énergies renouvelables
vous voyez apparaître des conflits
d'usagé des sols par exemple pour faire
pousser des cultures à des fins
énergétiques
ça revient directement en conflit avec
les cultures à usage alimentaire
donc en fait ça veut dire qu'on est
obligé pour une partie de l'énergie
qu'on utilise de revenir au sol par
rapport à l' avantage qu'on avait eu de
se contenter de taper dans le sous sol
donc on revient à un système en deux
dimensions
alors qu'on avait réussi à passer à un
système en 3 une certaine haine quelques
ordres de grandeurs d'usagé énergétique
courant alors ce truc est très vieux
donc l'ordre de grandeur est toujours
valable
il ya probablement un facteur de à la
baisse qui s'est baladé pour certains
d'entre eux mais c'est pas grave ça vous
fixent des idées
ce que vous voyez alors tout ça je peux
le traduire en jour esclaves ce que j'ai
fait retenez surtout en gardant ce
graphique que l'essentiel de la
consommation d'énergie d'un occidental
donc des machines qui le mobilise à son
profit c'est pas la lumière et c'est pas
l'état son café recyclable
donc là où je vais m'adresser à des
ingénieurs qui sont censés manipuler les
ordres de grandeur c'est pas avec des
petits gestes qu'on évite des gros
problèmes
on peut avoir des petits gestes pour
s'attaquer aux gros problèmes mais ça ne
remplace pas le fait de s'attaquer au
gros problème alors je vous le dis parce
que dans le monde dans lequel je vis qui
est le monde des entreprises
c'est quand même très très fréquent
qu'on fasse une confusion sur les ordres
de grandeurs délibéré 1
on se cache derrière son petit doigt on
dit en garde et ses fabuleux j'ai
installé une ruche sur le toit et puis
j'ai mis des gobelets recyclables à la
cantine et puis un jour par an les gens
vont venir en vélo et non ça marche pas
comme ça évidemment donc ici vous avez
quelques ordres de grandeur sur des
consommations énergétiques
vous voyez que
quelque chose qui va peser très lourd
c'est ce qu'on achète et la façon dont
on se déplace quand on parlera
changement climatique on verra aussi que
la façon dont on mange et quelque chose
de significatif et la façon dont on loge
donc en gros la taille du logement qu'on
occupe l'énergie qu'on utilise pour
l'occuper la quantité de trucs condé on
achète dans l'année et la façon dont on
se déplace et le nombre de kilomètres
qu'on fait dans l'année c'est beaucoup
plus impactant que le fait de fermer la
lumière ou pas derrière soi quand on
sort d'une pièce c'est pas du tout le
même ordre de grandeur
alors dans le même temps que par
personne parce que jusqu'à maintenant je
vous ai parlé de par personne
les ordres de grandeur ont
fondamentalement changé la taille de la
population a aussi fondamentalement
changé vous avez ici une reconstitution
approximative évidemment parce qu'il ya
dix mille ans lindsay était un peu moins
performante qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une
reconstitution approximative de la
population urbaine
alors pourquoi il ya dix mille ans
pourquoi ce graphique des mariés dix
mille ans
que denis non aux grandes villes non
c'est la sédentarisation des hommes
s'est recueilli à dix mille ans et on
verra ça au moment du cours sur le
changement climatique
nous sortons nous terminons la sortie de
la dernière ère glaciaire
nous arrivons au début de l'ère
interglaciaire chaude qui est celle
qu'on avait connue jusqu'au moment où on
a commencé à mettre en route le
changement climatique d'origine humaine
c'est-à-dire une période de stabilité à
très forte
on va dire du climat qui permet la
sédentarisation des hommes c'est à dire
que à climat stable
la ressource qui vous permet de vous
nourrir elle se balade pas un peu
partout parce que lequel elle se balade
au gré du climat qui change encore elle
est toujours au même endroit
donc vous pouvez commencer à vous
sédentarisés à ce moment là les hommes
sont quelques millions sur terre quand
je dis encore une fois l'insee est pas
extrêmement performante
à cette époque là au début de la
révolution industrielle
alors je rappelle espérance de vie à la
naissance des habitants de la planète
terre en 1800 c'est un peu moins de 30
ans soit dit en passant c'est est
inférieure en ville qu'à la campagne
parce que à l'époque la ville était un
lieu de concentration des miasmes de
toutes sortes et donc dès qu'il y avait
une maladie c'était beaucoup plus facile
de l'attraper et d'en mourir que quand
vous étiez à la campagne vous aviez
également la même chose pour la
mortalité infantile
on est un milliard est ce que vous voyez
c'est que en l'espace de deux siècles on
a connu une évolution qui est plus
proche de l'hyperbole co2
l'exponentielle dans le même temps où la
quantité de ressources de toutes sortes
consommée par individu a également cru
alors en fait une partie des gens que je
connais moins inclus se pose la question
de savoir si cette évolution
démographique aurait pris place si on
n'avait pas eu l'énergie abondante
parce que si on n'avait pas eu l'énergie
abondante s'est pas complètement sûr que
les rendements céréaliers serait passé
de 10 à 80 quintaux hectare en
ile-de-france s'est pas complètement sûr
qu' on aurait pu transporter de la
nourriture partout là où on en a besoin
à partir de là où elle pousse s'est pas
complètement sûr qu'on aurait su la
préserver contre le chaud le froid et
toutes les petites bêtes qui ont envie
de la manger à notre place c'est pas
complètement sûr qu'on aurait pu amener
l'eau potable et évacuer les miasmes des
villes c'est paco et c'est donc il ya
tout un tas de trucs qui sont pas
complètement sûr dans
monde on n'aurait pas eu l'énergie
fossile est donc ce n'est pas
complètement sûr qu'on serait passé à
sept milliards d'individus
et si la question se pose de savoir si 7
ou 8 milliards d'individus c'est pas une
conséquence de l'énergie abondante à ce
moment évidemment la question corollaire
se pose qui est à partir du moment où
l'on rentre en décrue énergétique forte
est-ce qu'on reste à 8 milliards
d'individus s'est pas complètement sûr
non plus si je fais population fois
usage individuel
voilà ce à quoi j'ai abouti sur la
quantité totale d'énergie utilisée par
les hommes
c'est à dire en gros l'évolution du parc
de machines sachant qu'entre ici et là
il faut beaucoup moins d'énergie pour
faire fonctionner une machine parce que
vos prédécesseurs et les miens ont été
astucieux sur la manière de faire
fonctionner les machines et donc ont
gagné en efficacité et donc ce que vous
voyez là c'est un minorant du parc de
machines en fonctionnement dans le monde
donc là à mon avis on est proche du parc
de machines et là c'est plutôt un
dixième du parc de machines en
fonctionnement dans le monde
ce que vous voyez c'est que entre la
génération de mes parents et la
génération de mes enfants
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par les
hommes a été multiplié par un petit
facteur 10 et à mon avis avec le gard
d'efficacité énergétique qui a eu dans
le même laps de temps le parc de
machines en fonctionnement dans le monde
a été multiplié par un facteur de
quelques dizaines s'est pas complètement
certain qu'entre vous et la génération
de vos petits enfants il se passe la
même chose
c'est même assez certain qu'il va pas se
passer ça donc c'est assez certains que
le monde que vous allez connaître et moi
pour les quelques décennies qui me reste
à vivre
si tout va bien ne sera pas un monde de
prolongation tendancielle de ce que nous
avons eues dans le passé
je vous rappelle que les systèmes
physiques sont exceptionnellement des
systèmes binaires en général c'est des
systèmes non linéaire et que dans les
systèmes non linéaire vous pouvez pas
raisonner par induction
il vaut mieux éviter
si je regarde la marque de l'homme sur
son environnement
je peux la proximité la marque de
l'homme sur son environnement par la
quantité d'énergie qu'il met en jeu
puisque je le redis la quantité
d'énergie qu'on met en jeu c'est le flux
de transformation que nous opérons par
définition même de ce que c'est que
l'énergie donc pour ça je prends
l'énergie par personne fois la
population et ça me donne quelque chose
qui ressemble à l'évolution de la marque
de l'homme sur son environnement
et bien voilà la population je fais fois
l'énergie utilisée par personne et voilà
au premier ordre
comment a évolué la marque de l'homme
sur son environnement sur une planète
qui faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre à ce moment là et qui fait
toujours 13 mille kilomètres de diamètre
à ce moment là et donc vous comprenez
que les problèmes d'environnement qu'on
a aujourd'hui ne sont pas nécessairement
des problèmes qui se qualifie de façon
différente par rapport à ce qu'on avait
dans le passé par contre il se quantifie
de façon différente par rapport à ce
qu'on avait dans le passé nous avons
aujourd'hui un tout petit problème
d'ordre de grandeur
et quand vous voyez ça vous comprenez
aussi qu'on a un tout petit peu 1000
systèmes horde équilibre et que c'est
pas complètement sûr qu'il va rester
dans cet état pendant extrêmement
longtemps
alors là je suis en train de vous
préparer à quelque chose que je vous
détaillerai dans l'est dans d'autres
cours qui est que le pardon le il va se
passer de toute façon des choses à
l'avenir
et de toute façon à l'avenir le monde ne
restera pas stable de toute façon et
donc nous avons vous avez j'ai
essentiellement le choix entre j'attends
que l'instabilité arrive comme elle a
envie d'arriver et je la subis ou je
déclenche l'instabilité dans les limites
de ce que j'arrive encore à peu près à
contrôler mais ça sera là où l'autre
de petits compléments sur l'évolution de
la quantité d'énergie utilisée dans le
monde vous avez ici le la variation de
la quantité utilise d'énergie utilisée
par les hommes entre 2000 et 2010 est ce
que vous voyez c'est que nonobstant le
discours médiatique sur le fait que
c'est vachement bien parce que on a de
plus en plus de production éolienne et
solaire que vous voyez là les trois
énergies qui ont le plus augmenté sur la
période est de très loin
c'est les trois énergies fossiles et en
particulier le charbon donc l'énergie
fossile qui a le plus augmenté depuis
qu'on a commencé à faire des grands
débats sur le climat c'est le charbon le
charbon sur cette période a augmenté
plus de dix fois plus que l'éolien 1 que
le solaire pardon compter en équivalent
primaire et plus de cinq fois plus que
le solaire donc si le journal avait une
pagination reflétant l'effet pour un
article vous parlant du solaire et
devrait y en avoir 15 ou parlant du
charbon d'accord c'est ça qui devrait se
passer et si vous regardez aujourd'hui
ce que vous avez comme approvisionnement
donc je vous fais le camembert sur
l'évolution historique que je vous ai
montré juste avant vous voyez que c'est
les combustibles fossiles qui domine
l'approvisionnement mondial de la tête
et des épaules
en premier lieu le pétrole ensuite le
charbon et le gaz
si je regarde juste les énergies
renouvelables vous voyez que ce qui
arrive en tête c'est le bois suivi de
l'hydroélectricité je vous signale que
les deux premiers termes de
l'approvisionnement renouvelables de la
france celle et de même le bois et
l'hydroélectricité
c'est pas parce que le journal à nouveau
vous parle d'éolien et de solaire que
c'est ça qui compte le plus dans
l'approvisionnement renouvelables
français c'est le bois l
hydroélectricité de très loin les autres
termes après sont beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus faible et donc voilà
l'approvisionnement renouvelables
français petit graphique que j'étais pas
plus tard qu'hier avec des statistiques
qui ont été publiés pas plus tard qu'il
ya une semaine ou quinze jours ce que
vous voyez c'est que les deux premiers
termes de très loin de
l'approvisionnement renouvelables
français c'est le bois qui sert
essentiellement au chauffage et
l'hydroélectricité qui sert à faire de
l'électricité
ici vous avez l'éolien et le solaire
vous voyez que le solaire est en fait un
des termes les plus faibles de
l'approvisionnement
renouvelables français derrière plein
d'autres trucs
les pompes à chaleur les déchets etc
l'ensemble de ces énergies renouvelables
donc là c'est des millions de tonnes
équivalent-pétrole vous avez dit que
vous en parlerai des tonnes équivalent
pétrole dans une consommation française
qui fait à peu près 250 avec cette même
unité
donc vous voyez ce que représentent les
énergies renouvelables dans cet ensemble
voilà je vous lâche pour cinq minutes
profitez-en pour faire garder beaucoup à
ce moment là mais cinq minutes à un
quart d'heure merci je vais un tout
petit peu revenir maintenant au prix
vous avez probablement un certain
d'entre vous entendu dire j'y reviendrai
au prochain court mais je vais déjà
faire un petit aperçu aujourd'hui que le
prix de l'énergie qui ne se discute pas
au dernier rang de 7 ans fille doit
fortement augmenté si l'énergie devient
plus rare ce qui va ce qu'il ya comme
corollaire qu'une énergie plus
abondantes devraient voir son prix
fortement baissé le prix de toutes les
énergies en fait il est plus ou moins a
servi au prix du pétrole
ici vous avez donc le prix du pétrole
exprimées en monnaies constantes c'est à
dire en mode est corrigée de l'inflation
depuis un siècle et demi vous voyez
quelque chose d'assez intéressant c'est
que ce prix du pétrole en fait sur
tendance longue il ya un siècle pendant
lequel il est rigoureusement stable
exprimées en monnaies constantes
indépendamment de la quantité produite
vous voyez qu au moment du choc
pétrolier qui caractérise une forte
variation de la dérive et c'est à dire
la production monte rapidement et s
arrête de monter rapidement le prix
augmente fortement fille revient plus ou
moins à son niveau d'avant puis de
nouveau vous avez un choc ou le prix
augmente fortement et revient à quelque
chose qui est pas très très loin de son
niveau d'avant
donc l'idée que le prix du pétrole est
quelque chose qui suit l'abondance de
l'offre n'est pas confirmée par ce
graphique que vous voyez là par contre
le vrai prix des choses en fait c'est
pas le prix ont exprimé en monnaie c'est
le prix rapporté à la seule
grandeur qui reste incompressibles au
cours du temps c'est à dire 24 heures
dans une journée
dit autrement le vrai prix de n'importe
quoi c'est pas le prix exprimée en
argent c'est le prix exprimée en minutes
de temps de travail
si vous voulez exprimer un prix en
minutes de travail ça veut dire que vous
devez rapporté un prix à ce que les gens
gagnent et donc vous devez rapporté le
prix du pétrole en l'occurrence à ce que
les gens gagnent que vous voyez ici
c'est à dire le pib par personne et là à
ce moment on retombe sur nos pattes
vous voyez que sur le siècle et demi qui
vient de s'écouler ou sur le siècle qui
vient de s'écouler
le prix d'un baril de pétrole a été
divisée par aller 15 à 20 ce qui veut
dire qu'avec l'efficacité des machines
qui a augmenté dans le même temps le
prix d'un kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique lui a été divisée par 50 à 100
on retrouve le même facteur diviseur que
celui que vous avez quand on compare le
prix d'une énergie renouvelable ancienne
avec le prix d'une énergie fossile
moderne on va toujours retomber sur ce
facteur diviseur où ce facteur
multiplicateur de quelques dizaines à
une centaine qui représente aussi le
passage d'un être humain produisant avec
ses bras et ses jambes à 200 équivalents
esclaves par personne donc en gros par
quelques boucs vous preniez le problème
le passage de la civilisation
renouvelables à la civilisation fossile
a été l'apparition de superman ou d'iron
man pour chacun d'entre nous avec une
multiplication par un ordre de grandeur
de la centaine plusieurs centaines de la
capacité d'action sur le sur
l'environnement est évidemment du coup
tous les sous produits indésirables de
cette capacité d'action ont aussi été
multiplié par plusieurs centaines
donc on a supprimé beaucoup de surface
pour les autres êtres vivants ce pour ça
qu'il ya une perte de biodiversité
on a induit beaucoup de pollution dans
l'environnement de toute nature dont il
ya tout un tas de substances
indésirables qu'on est venu rajouter
dans l'environnement à mesure qu'on
d'augmenter les flux de transformation
c'en est une conséquence parfaitement
logique si on regarde une période plus
récente par contre ici vous avez le prix
de l'énergie rapporté à ce que les
français gagnent et ben vous voyez que
les gilets jaunes
on peut être raison pour et ont sûrement
raison pour leur cas particulier
ils ont tort pour la population dans son
ensemble puisque le prix de l'énergie
rapporté à ce que les gens gagnent en
première approximation on a à peu près
jamais été aussi bas qu'aujourd'hui
donc quand on dit ah le litre d'essence
à 1 euro 50 hockey sauf qu'on oublie que
la fiche de paye des gens a augmenté à
due proportion est même un peu plus vite
alors j'ai déjà dit de manière implicite
je vais leur dire de manière plus
explicite cette énergie abondante vous
permet d'être assis aujourd'hui dans cet
amphi et d'une façon générale a
radicalement changé le monde qui nous
entoure en ce qui concerne les travaux
leur travail les métiers
la quasi totalité des gens vous
connaissez aujourd'hui travaillent dans
les services travaillent en ville et
travaille dans tertiaire libyen la quasi
totalité des gens vous connaissez c'est
une situation très récente qui est la
conséquence de l'augmentation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
vous avez ici l'évolution des effectifs
salariés en france
des composés entre agriculteurs envers
ouvriers en noir et employés des
services en bleu ces trois courbes porte
sur deux siècles
alors je fais une petite parenthèse plus
vous avez des séries longues quand vous
intéresser à un processus mieux vous
vous portez la meilleure manière de
faire un contresens sur l'interprétation
d'un processus c'est d'avoir une série
qui est trop courte par rapport aux
échelles caractéristiques de temps de
variation de ce que vous êtes en train
de regarder
donc il faut avoir des séries un peu
longue si on veut comprendre quelque
chose
ce que vous voyez ces cadeaux siècle les
deux tiers de la population active
travaillent dans l'agriculture
ce sont donc des paysans vous en
déduisez également une chose de cette
affaire-là c'est que si les deux tiers
de la population active sont dans les
champs c'est que la productivité d'un
agriculteur à cette époque là est
suffisant pour se nourrir lui plus une
demi personne qui fait autre chose
c'est ça que ça veut dire
donc un agriculteur c'est nourrir une
virgule cinq personnes et puis vous
voyez que là les effectifs dans
l'agriculture augmente doucement
doucement comme le volume jusqu'en 1850
alors qu'est ce qui se passe à cette
époque vous n'avez pas à cette époque
une augmentation significative de la
productivité agricole
en gros un agriculteur de 1850 est à peu
près aussi productif qu'un agriculteur
de 1800 un peu plus peut pas beaucoup
par contre ce qui se passe c'est que la
population augmente et donc on coupe des
forêts pour augmenter les surfaces
cultivées ont fait de la déforestation
en europe exactement comme on fait de la
déforestation actuellement en amérique
latine ou en asie du sud est
exactement comme on en a fait aux états
unis et en russie à toute époque
l'augmentation démographique à supposer
pour les populations sédentaires qui on
coupe des forêts pour installer des
surfaces cultivées à la place c'est ce
que font les européens et donc les
français et donc on coupe des forêts
jusqu'au moment où il y en a plus
beaucoup à couper c'est à dire qu'en
1850 on passe par le minimum forestier
15% de la france est couverte de forêts
pas plus aujourd'hui c'est 25
il est 15 pour cent couverts de forêts
sont essentiellement des surfaces
compliquer la cultiver les montagnes
notamment
et puis l'industrie commencent à
développer des auxiliaires pour
l'agriculture qui rendent l'agriculteur
plus productifs commence à développer
les colliers très on commence à
développer des charrues en commun etc
c'est le début des forges et de
l'industrie qui permet de multiplier les
auxiliaires pour l'agriculteur la
première moissonneuse batteuse de
mémoire c'est la fin du 19e siècle début
du 20ème siècle s'est tirée par des
chevaux à l'époque évidemment et donc on
amène des auxiliaires aux agriculteurs
qui permettent de diminuer le nombre
d'agriculteurs pour les remplacer par
des machines ou par des animaux très
dans l'est dans les champs à ce moment
évidemment ça libère des bras pour que
une partie des gens et faire autre chose
et ça alimente mais pas que la
croissance des effectifs dans les autres
secteurs
et puis après guerre alors là pour le
coup iron man va arriver pour de vrai
vous avec iron man est une création
américaine c'est les comics de marvel
bien c'est vraiment les américains
en l'occurrence les américains amènent
les tracteurs et les engrais qu'ils
avaient commencé à développer chez eux
et on va remplacer les agri que le les
effectifs humains et les animaux de
trait par beaucoup plus efficace c'est à
dire les tracteurs et les engrais
moyennant quoi comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais je le répète le rendement
céréalier en beauce par exemple a été
multiplié par 6 et 8
entre 1945 et 1975 6 à 8
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
et à ce moment on peut libérer
énormément de paires de bras et de
jambes qui sont dans l'agriculture pour
les envoyer ailleurs alors où est ce
qu'on les envoie rieur et ben on les
envoie dans l'industrie alors industrie
ou artisanat c'est la même chose alors
dans l'industrie et l'artisanat on va
être capable grâce à l'approvisionnement
énergétique croissant de mettre en route
une quantité croissante de match idéale
à chaque fois que j'ai une machine qui
se met en route j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
pour la piloter
j'ai une chaîne de production de
voitures j'ai des ouvriers qui
travaillent sur la chaîne j'ai un
marteau piqueur j'ai besoin d'un ouvrier
pour actionner le marteau piqueur j'ai
une grue j'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour
actionner la grue
donc on va construire de plus en plus de
machines et il se trouve que
l'approvisionnement énergétique à cette
époque là nous sommes aux trente
glorieuses vous avez vu la vitesse à
laquelle le pétrole par personne
augmente
l'approvisionnement énergétique à ce
moment-là augmente plus vite par
personne que la taille unitaire de la
machine c'est une séquence de faux seins
et donc malgré le fait que j'ai de plus
en des machines de plus en plus grosse
je peux créer de plus en plus d'emplois
parce que le flux le parc de machines
en gros il augmente le parc de machines
augmente parce que la taille unitaire de
la machine augmente moins vite que
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne donc je peux augmenter le
nombre de machines donc augmenter le
nombre d'emplois dans l'industrie après
les chocs pétroliers
celle inverse la taille unitaire de la
machine continue d'augmenter alors que
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personnes s'arrêtent d'augmenter
à ce moment j'ai besoin de moins en
moins de monde pour piloter des machines
qui sont par ailleurs de plus en plus
grosse et qui vont continuer à augmenter
la production industrielle la production
industrielle en france a doublé entre
1974 et 2007 donc après les chocs
pétroliers on sait pas d industrialiser
on a fait une autre industrie - de
chaussettes et plus d'avions par contre
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la taille
unitaire de la machine à continuer
d'augmenter alors même que
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne lui arrêtait d'augmenter donc
on a diminué les effectifs dans
l'industrie pour actionner des machines
unitairement plus grosse et dont
l'ensemble produisait plus mais là ce
que je regarde c'est le nombre de gens
c'est pas la puissance productive
donc le nombre de gens baissent et on a
également une deuxième catégorie
d'emploi qui augmente qui sont des
emplois a servi à l'industrie alors là
aussi quelque chose qui est très
important à avoir en tête c'est que les
emplois de service n'existe pas sans
flux physiques un emploi de service
comme enseignant par exemple si vous
n'avez pas des flux physiques pour faire
un bâtiment d'enseignement
si vous n'avez pas des flux physiques
pour amener les élèves et l'enseignant
sur place donc des moyens de transport
si vous n'avez pas des flux physiques
pour faire du matériel pédagogique des
livres dans les temps anciens des
ordinateurs aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
de système d'enseignement
prenez un médecin en médecin si vous
n'avez pas de quoi fabriquer des
médicaments du matériel médical à
l'hôpital des appareils d'imagerie
l'hôpital lui-même et les moyens de
transport pour faire fonctionner tout ça
vous n'avez pas de médecin si vous
n'avez pas de voiture fabriquée
vous n'avez pas de banquier pour faire
du crédit automobile
vous n'avez pas d'assureur pour assurer
les automobiles vous n'avez pas de
moniteur d'auto école pour apprendre à
conduire et vous n'avez pas d'agents de
police pour vérifier que les gens
conduisent bien tous ces emplois
deviennent inutiles alors que c'est des
emplois de service dans un monde dans
lequel vous n'avez pas le flux physiques
sous jacents qui est de fabriquer les
voitures donc un truc qu'il faut se
sortir de la tête et du ray je vais vous
montrer les corrélations dans pas
longtemps qui montrent que c'est plus
fort et on se sortir de la tête c'est
l'idée que un monde
riche en emplois de service est un monde
dématérialisé c'est l'exact inverse un
monde riche en emplois de service est un
monde dans lequel il ya énormément de
flux à gérer et c'est pour ça que vous
avez besoin de énormément de gens pour
vous en occuper donc les emplois de
services augmentent à mesure que la
production industrielle augmente parce
qu'il faut continuer il faut gérer il
faut vendre il faut assurer il faut
gérer il faut enseigner etc et vous
voyez que là il ya une période où les
emplois de service continue d'augmenter
parce que la production industrielle
continue d'augmenter alors même que les
emplois industriels se mettent à baisser
par contre à partir de 2007 moment où la
production industrielle arrête
d'augmenter en europe
on commence également à avoir un sujet
sur les emplois de service et vous voyez
également apparaître une nouvelle
catégorie qui n'existait pas avant au
moment des chocs pétroliers
c'est le chez les chômeurs c'est à dire
que l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne n'augmente en plus en gros vous
n'arrivez plus donc la productivité du
travail augmente peu puisque la
productivité du travail ses adjoints des
machines la productivité du travail
augmente peu et il se met et les emplois
existants sont trop productif pour que
dans une économie qui a arrêté de
croître rapidement vous puissiez donner
un travail à tout le monde
dit autrement à partir des chocs
pétroliers on rentre dans une époque où
la seule manière de donner du travail à
tout le monde c'est de diminuer la
productivité des gens au travail en est
là l'équation est les diverses selon les
pays certains n'acceptent pas et à ce
moment il crée des chômeurs la france
d'autres acceptent et à ce moment il se
met à créer des jobs mal payés mal
qualifié petits boulots à temps partiel
etc
c'est les systèmes plus libéraux anglais
allemands américains etc
mais c'est l'un des deux embranchements
qui se met en place
alors ça c'est l'évolution dynamique en
france maintenant je vais vous montrer
quelques évolutions statiques ou
dynamiques qui corroborent ce que je
viens de dire ici vous avez un graphique
dans lequel avec les données de la
banque mondiale chaque point représente
un pays en abscisse j'ai la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par personne sert le
parc de machines par personne en moyenne
dans le pays et en ordonnée j'ai la
fraction de la population active qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture
et bah vous et que c'est très simple
c'est 10 - combien il ya d'énergie par
personne dans le pays et je te dirai
quel est la fraction de la population
active qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture
d'accord c'est très simple après voilà
un autre graphique qui va vous dire la
même chose ici c'est l'évolution de 1991
à 2014 de deux données dans le monde
donc la série en moyenne mondiale c'est
les émissions de co2 par personne que
vous avez là et la fraction de la
population active dans l'agriculture
eh bien vous voyez que plus les
émissions de co2 augmente ce qui est le
cas quand vous suivez leur chronologique
et plus donc plus vous avez d'énergie
fossile par personne - vous avez
d'agriculteurs dans la population active
alors c'est vrai pour le monde mais
c'est vrai par exemple pour l'inde
mais c'est vrai par exemple pour la
chine et c'est vrai pour le brésil enfin
je g250 pays dans la base de données je
voulais sort pas tous mais c'est quelque
chose que vous constatez à peu près
partout donc vous mettez de l'énergie
dans un pays ça veut dire que vous
mettez des machines dans le pays vous
sortez des paysans de l'agriculture
prêta et donc vous créez un exode rural
partout pareil
par ailleurs l'augmentation de la
productivité agricole nous a permis
d'augmenter la quantité d'animaux qu'on
mange
puisque il faut plus de surfaces ou des
surfaces plus productive pour manger des
animaux qu'ils auront eux-mêmes besoin
de manger ce qui pousse 80% que ce qui
pousse en france sert à nourrir des
animaux
c'est vrai pour les prairies c'est vrai
pour la totalité du maïs fois soufflé
quelques grains des marques que je ne
nommerai pas et c'est vrai pour la
moitié du blé c'est vrai pour la
totalité la quasi-totalité du soja qu'on
cultive dans le monde qui est une des
quatre en céréales qu'on cultive et
c'est donc en gros 80 % dans les pays
occidentaux des surfaces cultivées
servent à nourrir des animaux que vous
allez manger derrière est ce que vous
voyez ici alors là je vous ai pas mis
l'énergie je vous ai mis les gaz à effet
de serre peu importe ce que vous voyez
c'est que dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre liées à l'alimentation
là où il ya de la viande ou du poisson
vous avez une partie liée aux
hydrocarbures qui est plus élevé est ce
que vous voyez c'est que le sens de
l'histoire à cause de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
croissance et d'aller de la gauche vers
la droite
historiquement on a mangé des céréales
et des oignons pour ça que les paysans
avant que les du bec des céréales et des
oignons puis on s'est mis à manger des
petits animaux
d'abord des oeufs en fin d'avant le
produit des petits animaux les yeux puis
petit animal lui-même après vous henri
iv faut que les gens puissent manger des
petits animaux la poule au pot 1
mais c'était déjà du déchet la poule au
pot parce qu'elle a pondu toute sa vie
j'avais un déchet en fin de vie la poule
manger la poule puis on s'est mis à
manger des poulets de chair puis on
s'est mis à manger des cochons puis on
s'est mis à manger des vaches
le fait de pouvoir élever des vaches
rien pour les manger c'est quelque chose
qui est la marque d'un pays qui est sous
perfusion énergétique
ça ne marche pas et l'archétype c'est
les états unis ça ne marche pas dans un
pays à l'approvisionnement énergétique
sans et à cause de la productivité a
mené par les machines cette alimentation
de plus en plus carnet nous coûte de
moins en moins cher vous avez ici la
part du budget des ménages ramener la
part de l'alimentation pardon dans le
budget des ménages aux etats-unis alors
c'est une série donc j'ai pris les états
unis parce que c'est facile de trouver
des séries longues sur les sites
américains malgré le génie des
les ingénieurs français trouver des
séries donc de cette nature en trois
clics de souris sur un site français est
quelque chose de très difficile pas
pourquoi mais donc en tout cas ça marche
très bien aux états unis donc aux états
unis ce que vous voyez c'est que il ya
un petit siècle
le budget alimentaire des ménages c'est
un quart de ce qu'ils gagnent et à
l'époque c'est essentiellement de la
restauration à domicile donc madame
michu pardon de ce propos sexiste mais
c'est la réalité achètent des produits
bruts aux paysans du coin ou à la place
du marché du coin effet le frichti pour
monsieur michu et elle-même à partir de
poireaux 2 2
de patates doivent être poulet
aujourd'hui quand vous allez acheter de
la nourriture
en fait l'essentiel de ce que vous
achetez 80% des achats alimentaires des
français passent par la grande
distribution l'essentiel de ce que vous
achetez n'est pas la nourriture
le ticket de caisse en sortie d'un
magasin de la grande distribution
c'est du salaire de caissière ou du
salaire d'ingénieurs de la boîte qui a
fait les terminaux de paiements
automatiques
peu importe c'est du de la location des
espaces c'est du salaire de magasinier
c'est du salaire de transporter ces du
chiffre d'affaires de volvo trucks c'est
du chiffre d'affaires de publicis et
c'est tout sauf de la bouffe
quand vous regardez le produit brut dans
ce que vous achetez dans les bons cas de
figure c'est un tiers de la facture dans
les mauvaises c'est 3%
prenons l'exemple d'une boîte de
courrier ça coûte une boîte de en
grandes surfaces les mauvais les pas bio
[Musique]
non sens et les audio qui coûte 3 euros
les
1 euro 50 en gros un donc un euro
cinquante pour 6 e donc comme vous êtes
plus fort que moi en calcul mental ça
mais l'offre et du rein ou 15 / 6 avec
combien savent et le boeuf à combien 25
centimes nous sommes d'accord est ce que
vous savez à combien le même off est
acheté en sortie de ferme
pas mal pas loin de 5 6 est donc vous
voyez rien sur une boîte 2 vous 0
transformation nous avons transformation
vous avez un facteur 4 entre la sortie
de ferme est ce que vous payez en sort
en sortie de caisse donc j'insiste le
ticket de caisse aujourd'hui c'est tout
sauf de la bouffe ce qui veut dire que
quand on fait une série sur dur est
longue
en fait vous avez une idée homogénéité
massive entre ce que vous regardez au
début de la série est ce que vous
regardez la fin de la série parce qu'au
début de la série c'est vraiment l'offre
telle qu'il sort de chez le fermier
achetés au marché par madame michu
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout ça est
donc en fait si vous regardez et dans le
hors domicile c'est encore pire
l'omelette au café du coin là c'est pas
un euro cinquante que vous allez la
payer vous allez la payer 5 euros ou 6
euros pour 3 e dans 75 centimes duff
d'accord donc vous rajoutez un facteur
10 donc ce que vous ce que donc là en
fait le vrai prix de la nourriture
aujourd'hui il a en gros était divisé
par un facteur 20 sur cette échelle de
temps
le reste est du service on retombe
encore à nouveau sur le facteur diviseur
de quelques dizaines alors ça varie
selon les produits
grâce à l'abondance énergétique cette
abondance énergétique nous a également
amené les moyens de transport retenez
sans rentrer dans les détails que plus
un moyen de transport est moderne et
plus sa consommation par kilomètre est
élevé donc on avait du vélo
on est la marche à pied on a eu du vélo
on a eu du but on a eu du train etc puis
aujourd'hui on à l'avion qui est le mode
de transport le plus énergivore par
personne de tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
une fois qu'on a eu ses moyens de
transport extrêmement performant on en a
profité aussi pour en faire autre chose
alors juste une petite incidente dans
les images et les hits et dans les
séries longues
vous avez un autre truc qu'il faut voir
c'est que avec le temps certains objets
peuvent ne plus être affectés uniquement
à leur fonction initiale
parce qu'une voiture aujourd'hui c'est
pas qu'un moyen de transport c'est aussi
un salon sur roulettes
donc c'est votre espace avoue que vous
transporter jusqu'à la porte du bureau
et ça c'est également quelque chose qui
a une valeur et c'est également un objet
de statut donc je fais une petite
parenthèse là aussi sur l'inamovibilité
des séries une voiture quand vous la
comparez à autre chose parfois c'est
difficile de savoir à quoi et alors
voilà dernier avatar de la voiture ça
c'est la voiture autonome bahi k
est ce que c'est une voiture est ce que
c'est un salon sur roulettes
est ce que c'est un ordinateur sur
roulettes qui accessoirement vous
transporte
c'est quoi ce truc là la voiture
autonome connectés donc vous avez de
temps en temps là aussi des
inhomogénéités qui voilà qui lui auquel
il faut faire attention mais pour en
revenir à l'objet premier est de se
déplacer
non les moyens plus ils sont modernes
plus il consomme par kilomètre non non
ce que je dis c'est que la voiture
consomme plus que l'avion qui est un
moyen plus moderne et la voiture
consomme consomme moins que l'avion
pardon et l'avion est plus moderne que
la voiture consomme plus que le train
qui est un truc plus anciens etc
et puisque est plus que le bus et le bus
lui-même consomme plus que le vélo qui
est plus ancien et c'est donc en gros
plus un moyen et moderne plus sa
consommation par kilomètre est élevé et
en fait c'est ce que je représente ici
ce que vous avez ici c'est un graphique
qui vous donne la quantité d'énergie
utilisée en gramme équivalent pétrole
donc france et ça ça ou ça c'est
vraiment du pétrole par passager
kilomètre
c'est ce que vous avez là et vous voyez
que avec le temps ça monte
c'est à dire que c'est plus faible pour
le train que pour le bus plus fait pour
le bus que pour la voiture plus faible
pour la voiture que pour l'avion et là
vous avez la quantité de voyageurs
kilomètres effectués dans l'année donc
la surface vous donne la quantité
d'énergie qui est affecté à chaque mode
de transport est donc là vous comprenez
que c'est la route qui domine
aujourd'hui le les transports qu'on
effectue et je le redis donc le sens de
l'histoire et d'être allé de moyens
économe vers des moyens moins économes
parce qu'il y avait de plus en plus
d'énergie disponible par personne qui
dans cette salle n'a jamais pris l'avion
2 j'ai bien compté ou pas j'aurais posé
la même question en 1950 il aurait fallu
que la pause dans l'autre sens c'est à
dire qui dans cette salle a déjà pris
l'avion et j'aurais probablement eu deux
mains qui se serait levé l'avion est un
truc qui aujourd'hui dans votre
catégorie socioprofessionnelle et dans
votre pays est un truc qu'on utilise
comme on respire
c'est extrêmement récente et soit dit en
passant quand vous aurez mon âge c'est
pas complètement sûr ce sera toujours le
cas
c'est extrêmement récent parce que c'est
quelque chose qui demande des très très
grande quantité d'énergie retenait qu'un
aller retour paris new york c'est une
très très grande baignoire de pétrole
ces 400 à 500 litres de pétrole par
personne pour un voyage c'est à dire à
peu près la même chose que la
consommation annuelle de quelqu'un qui
utilise sa voiture pour un voyage ça
fait beaucoup
donc l'ouverture sur l'étranger de
l'école des mines
en 2060 pas dans deux mines paristech
sujet moi je vis avec mon temps en 2060
s'est pas complètement exclu que ça
ressemble plus aux trains de nuit pour
aller en suède que l avion pour aller à
kuala lumpur watching you alors vous
reviendrez au bateau à moitié à voile
pour aller en chine ça vous prendra un
mois s'est offert des souvenirs et vous
voyez ici la façon dont les gens se
déplacent sur deux sur un siècle et demi
pension de siècle et vous avez en
échelle logarithmique ici le nombre de
kilomètres effectués par personne et par
jour et là vous avez les différents
moyens de transport donc vous voyez que
le cheval était ce qui donnait le plus
de
personne km par jour après la marche qui
est là en blanc il ya deux siècles
donc il ya deux siècles en gros le
trajet quotidien d'un être humain
c'était trois kilomètres à pied ça use
ça use
parce qu'il ya deux siècles comme vous
l'avez vu tout à l'heure
l'être humain ordinaire c'était un
paysan et donc il faisait l'aller retour
entre la ferme et les divers endroits où
ils avaient besoin de se promener pour
faire son boulot donc ses chants ses
vergers etc
ces prairies voilà ce qu'il faisait dans
la journée trois kilomètres et puis du
reste il vivait toute sa vie durant sans
aller à quelques centaines de kilomètres
de là après vous voyez donc le cheval
ici vous voyez l'essor de la voiture du
train pardon et puis vous voyez surtout
l'essor de la voiture là qui est devenu
le mode dominant de déplacement
aujourd'hui
mais l'année où la voiture a supplanté
la marche comme mode de transport
dominant en termes de passagers
kilomètres par jour c'est les années 50
moi j'étais pas des mets tout juste mes
parents et aînés est bien née donc mes
parents qui était déjà né à cette époque
là sont nés dans un monde dans lequel le
mode dominant de transport pour la
population dans son ensemble c'était la
marche à pied qui passe ils vous rendez
compte aussi de ce que ça signifie par
rapport au monde dans lequel vous vivez
vous
on a augmenté on a diminué le nombre de
paysans et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on a donc mis ces paysans
quelque part alors où est ce qu'on fait
commodément de l'industrie puis des
emplois tertiaires dans les villes
historiquement qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une ville c'est un lieu des changes
quand vous regardez les villes qui ont
été construites il ya longtemps
elles sont toutes organisées autour de
lieux des changes qui sont la place de
marché
j'échange des biens le lieu de culte
j'échange des croyances et des règles
morales donc l'église pour parler de la
france est toujours au centre la mairie
ou équivalent c'est à dire j'échange des
règles de vie en commun l'école je les
change des savoirs donc les lieux des
changes sont au centre et
géométriquement le truc le plus efficace
c'est un disque avec tout le monde
autour ses accès plus compact
le disque est la forme la plus compacte
autour des lieux des changes qui sont
tous placés au centre
une fois que vous développez des des
moyens abondant de produire et de
transporter à ce moment il va se
produire deux phénomènes
1 vous allez vider des campagnes de vous
allez mettre les gens là où c'est plus
efficace un de produire et ensuite
d'échanger la production ou est ce que
c'est le plus efficace nous produire et
d'échangés la production dans les villes
c'est dans les villes que c'est plus
efficace de faire un don vous allez
mettre les gens dans les villes et en
augmentant l'énergie donc c'est là que
je veux en venir
vous augmentez la part de la population
qui habite en ville alors voilà comment
ça se passe pour le monde dans son
ensemble en 1960 vous avez 30 % d'un peu
plus de 30% de la population qui habite
en ville avec trois tonnes de co2 par
personne ce qui représente l'énergie
fossile qu'on utilise c'est à dire
l'énergie tout court en première
approximation et vous voyez qu
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 5 tonnes qu'on
a augmenté d'énergie et ça a permis de
mettre quasiment la moitié de la
population
pendant les deux tiers de la population
dans les villes alors cette évolution
vous la voyez à vitesse accélérée dans
les pays qui ont eu accès à vitesse
accélérée à l'énergie oui oui parce que
vous déformez la structure de l'emploi
est parce qu un système dans lequel vous
auriez laisser tous les artisans chacun
dans leur coin avec des transports
intermédiaire c'est beaucoup moins
efficace qu'un système dans lequel vous
mettez 100 artisans ensemble ça
s'appelle des ouvriers dans un seul dieu
que vous allez spécialisés pour une
production ça va devenir très efficace
je vais vous le dire autrement fabriquer
des voitures
si vous avez le boulon de 12 ce qui est
fait à brive puis ensuite la mise dans
la portière qui est fait à aurillac
et puis ensuite le bout de portières qui
est fait à bordeaux au pied sortez pas
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de tous
rassemblés au même endroit et d'avoir
des opérations qui sont assemblés au
même endroit après quand les transports
deviennent de plus en plus accessible
vous pouvez aller encore plus loin là
dedans et hyper spécialisés sur
certaines opérations sur certains sites
puisque transportez vous coûtent rien et
après à mener à d'autres endroits où en
masse vous hyper spécialisés sur autre
chose
c'est pour ça par exemple est un
constructeur qui assemble ses cabines de
camion à un autre endroit que là où il
dépeint et entre les deux vous
transportez des cabines de camion papin
vous avez exactement la même évolution
que vous pouvez constater sur la chine
la même pour le brésil la même pour la
thaïlande la même pour l'indonésie et
c'est plus d'énergie je le redis ça
déforme la structure de l'emploi de la
manière que je vous ai évoqué tout à
l'heure et les emplois qui apparaissent
sont les plus efficaces si vous êtes si
vous augmentez la taille des villes
alors vous pouvez augmenter la taille
des villes tout en les étalant et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe aussi quand
vous avez accès à l'énergie abondante
parce que à ce moment se déplacer en
mode mécanisée devient facile et donc
vous essayer de faire le meilleur des
deux mondes
c'est à dire un peu d'espacé autour de
chacun tout en ayant des flux d'échangés
extrêmement important et ça vous n'y
arrivez que si vous avez plein d'énergie
donc dans la ville sobres en énergie le
truc le plus compact qui soit celle
haussmannien paris est une des villes
les plus denses au monde malgré qu'on
n'ait pas de tours très haute
parce que quand vous avez des tours très
haute il faut commencer à laisser un peu
d'espacé autour des tours
c'est compliqué de serre et les tours
très haute comme vous serrez les
immeubles haussmanniens qui sont collés
les uns aux autres pas d'espacé entre
les immeubles donne tout sur la rue mais
après ils sont tous collés les uns aux
autres avec les tours de 10 étages ou de
30 étages c'est plus difficile de faire
ça et par ailleurs c'est le mode le plus
efficace quand vous n'avez pas une
énergie très abondante pour vous
déplacer parce que vous pouvez tout
faire à pied ou à la rigueur en
charrette à cheval
quand vous a donné une voiture à tout le
monde vous faites los angeles c'est hier
que vous conservez les mêmes fonctions
urbaines des changes en étant capable de
mettre la ville d'ensemble 150 km de
diamètre avec chacun ayant une voiture
vous garder les mêmes distances
parcourues en une heure dans un
urbanisme considérablement plus étalé
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle
quand vous regardez par exemple ile de
france
voilà à quoi ressemble à distance
domicile travail qui est représentative
de la densité de qui est représentative
des échanges du quotidien en 1975 dont
klaus et blanc c'est qu'on parcourt pas
grand chose alors en 1975 là vous avez
une ville dense les gens marchent pour
aller au boulot là vous êtes encore à la
campagne les gens marchent pour aller
dans leurs champs
et puis voilà comment ça a évolué au
cours du temps et voilà où nous sommes
au début des années 2000 tous ces gens
là sont devenus des urbains des
périurbains dont le métier est devenu un
métier de type urbain exemple les
agriculteurs
ils sont employés de l'industrie
employés des services donc ils sont
rentrés dans ce système de déplacement
qui est nécessaire à l'industrie et aux
services et ils utilisent leur bagnole
parce que là ya pas de transports en
commun qui en aura jamais et dont vous
vous mettez à avoir des distances
domicile-travail extrêmement forte
soit dit en passant là où on va mettre
le métro du grand paris c'est là dedans
donc eu ça va absolument pas réglé leur
problème
cette énergie abondante elle a également
permis d'augmenter le parc de logements
et elle a permis de l'augmenter plus
vite que la population en 1900 alors
allez on va dire au moment des chocs
pétroliers
le logement moyen en france faisait 77
m² vous aviez 3 un peu moins de trois
personnes dedans aujourd'hui vous avez
un peu plus de deux personnes par
logement
le logement lui-même étant devenus plus
grands alors les évidemment c'est
l'énergie qui a permis de faire ça et
donc l'énergie a permis notamment les
divorce parce que pour divorcer faut
avoir de logement là où vous n'aviez
qu'un sinon ça s'appelle pas un divorce
s'appelle des scènes de ménage et se
moulent elle s'appelle pas un divorce
divorce une séparation physique faut
avoir de quoi loger les gens les soit
dit en passant aujourd'hui un des
facteurs de pression à la hausse sur les
besoins en logements en france c'est le
divorce
ces problèmes le premier facteur de
pression à la hausse
vous retrouvez ce que je viens de vous
raconter dans ce petit graphique qui
vous donne cette fois ci en pour une
année donnée
les émissions de co2 par personne en
fonction de la part de l'emploi dans les
services et vous voyez que ce graphique
dit tout sauf le fait que quand vous
augmentez les emplois dans les services
en proportion les émissions diminuent
il vous dit tout sauf ça c'est la seule
chose que vous pouvez pas voir dans ce
trafic
alors voilà une autre manière
cette fois ci en dynamique pour le monde
dans son ensemble à nouveau vous avez la
part des emplois dans les services en
1991 et en 2014 avec les émissions de
co2 par personne et vous voyez que les
deux marches de concert et ça marche de
nouveau de concerts quand vous regardez
des pays
prix un parent ça marche à blanc autre
évolution que l'énergie abondante a
permis c'est l'augmentation du flux de
marchandises puisque les transports se
sont également appliqués aux camions là
il ya aussi quelque chose qu'il faut se
sortir de la cervelle qui est qu'on peut
dématérialiser les transports en les
remplaçant par des flux d'information
manifestement c'est pas vrai quand vous
regardez l'évolution concomitant des
flux d'information et des flux de
transport que ce soit soit dit en
passant des marchandises ou des
personnes vous arriver exactement au
même résultat
les deux évoluent de concert donc
aujourd'hui à l'échelle macroscopique
que de faire circuler plus
d'informations nous permettrait de faire
circuler moins deux personnes au moins
de marchandises c'est faux c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche
après on peut se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi ça marche pas comme ça
mais le résultat brut c'est qu'il suffit
pas d'augmenter la quantité
d'informations qui circulent pour se
dire ah ben là paf le résultat que je
vais obtenir c'est qu'il ya moins de
gens qui se déplacent ou moins de
marchandises qui se déplacent l'énergie
a donc restructurer le pays
ce que je vous présente pour la france
s'est appliqué dans tous les pays qui
ont eu accès à l'énergie tous vous aviez
des campagnes peuple et des villes pas
trop grosse
vous êtes passé à des villes beaucoup
plus grosse et des campagnes vides et
les villes se sont étalés et tous les
pays ont suivi la même évolution
les seuls pays qui ne l'ont pas suivi
c'est ce qu'ils ont eu des obstacles
géographiques qui se sont opposés à
cette évolution
alors je vais vous donner un exemple la
suisse la suisse a effectivement fait
grossir ces villes elle ne les a pas
beaucoup et aller pourquoi parce que
quand vous avez une ville qui est à fond
de vallée est allé la ville ça veut dire
grimper sur les flancs et c'est
compliqué alors ils l'ont fait un peu en
mettant des chalets un peu partout mais
ils n'ont pas fait de manière massive et
en particulier ils ont pas fait des
hypermarchés en périphérie de ville
parce que m l'hypermarché en terrasse
en haut de la ville c'est plus compliqué
que le maître en périphérie des villes
donc vous avez le mail etc et les pays
encore une fois qu'ils n'ont pas suivi
cette évolution c'est parce qu'ils ont
lu une barrière physique qui les a
empêchés de suivre cette énergie
abondante s'est également appliqué aux
loisirs alors un les loisirs ont
augmenté parce que comme les machines
produisent à notre place ça nous libère
du temps donc ça nous libère du temps
pour les études à l'époque où il n'y
avait pas de machines y avait pas
d'études longues
ça nous libère du temps pour la retraite
à l'époque où il y avait pas d'énergie
abondante y avait pas de retraite
ça nous libère du temps pour les
vacances ça nous libère du temps pour ne
rien faire le week-end et ça nous libère
du temps pour de travail et que 35
heures par semaine
tout ce temps libre que nous avons gagné
nous le devons à l'énergie abondante
donc là aussi retenu quelque chose qui
va s'appliquer non seulement à vous mais
aux gens avec qui vous allez travailler
et vivre pour le restant de vos jours
dans un monde à l'énergie contrainte
c'est pas l'augmentation du temps libre
bien géré on va dire qui va s'appliquer
ce que vous voyez ici c'est une des
occupations du temps libre qui savait le
tourisme est alors j'ai fait un petit
calcul il ya quelques il ya quelques
années je veux pas changer lors de
grandeur enfin je veux dire j'ai pas
refait le calcul mais l'heure de
grandeur est toujours le même et ça vous
donne les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc à nouveau la consommation
d'énergies fossiles liée à la façon dont
on passe ses vacances alors là dedans
j'ai fait rentrer le déplacement initial
le fait d'aller sur le lieu de vacances
en train en voiture en avion
j'ai fait rentrer la fabrication
éventuelle de l'objet dans lequel vous
habitez pendant vos vacances
la tente la caravane la résidence
secondaire j'ai constaté j'ai considéré
que si on la faisait construire je
comptais quelque chose si c'était la
vieille belle-mère qu'il faut se farcir
on comptait rien parce qu'elle avait
déjà sa maison qui était construite
depuis longtemps et puis j'ai également
pris en compte les déplacements locaux
s'il y en a et c
si c'est les vacances au ski j'ai pris
en compte le chauffage de l'appartement
puisqu'en général le ski c'est compliqué
quand il fait très chaud
c'est plutôt un peu froid et donc les
appartements surchauffés
préférentiellement aux violets
et c'est donc j'ai pris en compte tous
ces trucs là est ce que vous constatez
c'est que la forme de tourisme la plus
moderne celle ci un jeune ballet des
trois jours à l'hôtel en prenant l'avion
c'est également celle qui suppose la
plus grande quantité d'énergie consommée
pour s'offrir une semaine de vacances
inversement le premier ça et ça qu'ils
sont les formes de loisirs qui sont
apparus quand les congés payés sont
apparus dire que les gens prenaient leur
villa le vélo pour aller faire du
camping où il prenait le train pour
aller faire du camping c'est ça qu'ils
ont fait au début 1c les formes qui sont
les plus sobres en énergie fossile donc
en énergie tout court pour être exercés
donc à nouveau
l'abondance énergétique à déformer nos
modes de vie et on doit le fait de
pouvoir bénéficier de cette offre de
loisirs au fait que nous sommes sous
perfusion énergétique
tous autant que nous sommes c'est pour
ça que se développent actuellement on
est en suède par exemple depuis quelques
années parce que le on en parle dans les
médias depuis quelques semaines mais en
fait quand vous regardez les
statistiques ça date d'il ya quelques
années un début de diminution de la
quantité d'avions pris par les suédois
qui est maintenant qualifié par les
médias de honte de prendre l'avion alors
c'est parce que les candidats ont une
sensibilité environnementale plutôt plus
développé que le reste des européens ce
qui peut s'expliquer par des raisons
historiques et géographiques
on va retrouver ça sur le plan
économique avec ce que ça coûte
exprimée en heure de temps de travail de
prendre l'avion je vous redis le vrai
prix des choses c'est les heures de
temps de travail
est ce que vous constatez c'est que le
prix exprimée en heure de temps de
travail pour prendre l'avion a été
divisé par un facteur extrêmement
important
en l'espace de quelques décennies
c'est une autre façon de dire que
l'énergie est devenu plus abondante
c'est à dire que c'est plus facile de
s'en payer plein avec une heure de temps
de travail c'est la même façon
l'énergie actionner également des
machines industrielles et les machines
industrielles vont vous servir à
fabriquer tous les objets qui vous
entourent aujourd'hui donc les tables
sur lesquelles vous êtes à coude et pour
certains les chaises sur lesquelles vous
êtes assis tous les vêtements que vous
portez les lunettes pour certains les
chaussures etc tout ça ça a été fabriqué
par des machines industrielles alors
l'énergie actionne les machines
industrielles c'est donc l'exosquelette
qui permet de faire tous y compris les
ciseaux
les produits de beauté et le
les films de netflix mais ça sert
également comme matière première
donc vous avez dans l'énergie une
composante qu'on appelle parfois non
énergétiques en vous me direz le nom
énergétique dans l'énergie c'est quand
même un peu compliqué en fait quand vous
voyez des usages non énergétiques de
l'énergie notamment du pétrole et du gaz
c'est que ça sert de matière première
pour la chimie organique 1 toute la
chimie organique est basé sur des
dérivés du gaz et du pétrole la lia des
américains qui ont fait un petit test
rigolos ils ont sorti d'une maison tous
les produits qui contiennent des dérivés
du pétrole
bayard est rien en fait ils ont
également dû arracher les parquets
pascal du vernis sur les parquets il
aurait dû arracher les rideaux il aurait
dû arracher la tringle à rideaux il
aurait dû enlever la peinture
enfin il aurait dû tout enlever quoi
donc le pétrole aujourd'hui c'est pas
seulement quelque chose qui actionne une
machine c'est également la base de la
chimie organique pour fabriquer la
totalité des produits qui nous entourent
parce que vous n'avez à peu de choses
près pas un produit qui vous entourent
dans lequel vous n'ayez pas des dérivés
du pétrole
ces objets qui nous entourent
il faut les fabriquer derrière certains
d'entre eux vont également utiliser de
l'énergie
ici vous avez par exemple l'évolution du
taux en équipements électroménagers des
alors j'ai pas trouvé de série plus
récente ton équipement considérablement
augmenté partout mais vous avez
aujourd'hui par un ménage dans lequel
vous ayez pas un frigo un lave linge etc
vous avez tout un tas de trucs qui
utilisent de l'énergie donc on peut on à
l'industrie fabrique des objets et sa
demande de l'énergie est derrière ces
objets certains d'entre eux on va les
utiliser jusqu'à la tondeuse à gazon etc
et ça va également utiliser de l'énergie
et vous et que les taux d'équipement
augmentent en gros partout et tout le
temps je voulais déjà dit je le redis
divorce est énergivore
parce que quand on divorce il faut
doubler les logements du coup vous
doublez la consommation énergétique des
logements si les deux logements
son traitement ou l'augmenter à
proportion de la nouvelle surface
occupée
vous avez besoin de fabriquer plus de
logements ça utilisent de l'énergie
vous avez besoin de meubler deux fois
plus de logements alors il ya des trucs
que vous doublez pas vraiment mes trucs
que vous doublez par exemple vous avez
deux fois plus de lits chacun dort dans
un lit vous avez deux fois plus de
lavabos deux fois plus de plaque de
cuisson deux fois plus et c'est tout ça
il faut fabriquer quand il ya des
enfants pas toujours et quand il ya des
enfants il faut ensuite les a menés d'un
foyer à l'autre cela demande des
déplacements supplémentaires parfois
assez long comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure un certain nombre de choses qui
aujourd'hui sont considérées comme
normales
donc je redis encore une fois la
retraite les études etc
c'est l'énergie quand mitterrand en 1981
a dit tout le monde doit aller à
l'université
ce qui était la promesse implicite
derrière de tout le monde aura un emploi
de bureau
c'était une autre façon de dire je vous
promets la société de l'énergie
abondante un fini puisque je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure que tout le monde
dans un bureau c'est une société
extrêmement énergivore donc à l'époque
où mitterrand a dit il faut que tout le
monde aille à l'université en fait il a
fait la promesse implicite qu'on allait
pouvoir vivre dans un monde de machines
pour l'éternité
c'est ça la promesse implicite qu'il a
fait donc vous voyez que l'énergie c'est
pas du tout détachable de tout un tas de
trucs même et y compris de la façon dont
on envisage l'accès à la compétence
l'hôpital c'est très énergivore
également en france l'hôpital c'est à
peu près 5 % de l'empreinte carbone du
pays
donc comme l'a dit un humoriste célèbre
si c'est les vieux qui utilise le plus
de services de santé il a su priver la
dernière année de vie en attendant ça
pose quand même la question de savoir
combien de temps dans un monde à
l'énergie contrainte on pourra continuer
à arbitrer en faveur des gens qui
demandent un appareillage très lourd
alors qu'ils sont déjà très vieux et du
coup en défaveur de tous les autres y
compris les jeunes
voilà donc l'énergie est partout alors
une fois je vous ai dit ça on va faire
un tout petit peu d'économies voilà la
planète terre alors la planète terre
comme disait coluche écart avec les yeux
dans les coins de la planète terre est
constitué de ressources dans une vision
anthropocentrique donc je vais me placer
du point de vue des hommes et du point
de vue des hommes la planète terre c'est
des ressources
d'accord c'est là c'est notre maison
c'est là où nous vivons donc c'est des
ressources auxquelles on a accès ces
ressources vers les rangées en deux
catégories qui sont d'une part les
ressources qui se renouvellent sur des
échelles de temps court tu les appelles
renouvelables et d'autre part des
ressources qui ne se renouvelle pas sur
des échelles de temps courte que
j'appelle non renouvelable le minerai de
cuivre est définitivement non
renouvelables n'y a pas de transmutation
à large échelle sur terre qui réalimente
le stock de minerai de cuivre les
combustibles fossiles c'est renouvelable
si vous attendez quelques dizaines de
millions d'années c'est quand même pas
une échelle de temps courte donc l'école
dans non renouvelable par contre l'herbe
où le rayonnement solaire ça s'est
raisonnablement renouvelables sur des
échelles de temps courte ces ressources
sont toutes gratuites et elles sont le
résultat de tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis le big bang
l'ensemble étant gratuit donc depuis le
big bang soupe de protons puis tout le
reste tout a pas de processus ont pris
place et aujourd'hui nous avons
gratuitement le tableau de mendeleïev et
toutes les combinaisons qui nous offrent
à la surface de la planète
tout ça a été fait gratuitement là
dedans on arrive et on décide d'avoir
une activité productive
alors qu'est ce que c'est que l'activité
productive pour les hommes c'est se
servir dans ce grand dans cette grande
corne d'abondance de ressources et
transformer les ressources pour en faire
autre chose qui est plus intéressant que
la ressource initiale
par exemple j'ai décidé que ce brut
c'est plus intéressant d'avoir des silex
taillés pour courir derrière mes proies
par exemple j'ai dessert c'est plus
intéressant d'avoir des bois de serre
taillé pour en faire un certain nombre
de choses et c'est donc l'activité
productive des hommes c'est juste je me
sers dans les ressources existantes je
les transforme transformation énergie
j'utilise de l'énergie à l'époque
évidemment juste celle de mes bras de
mes jambes et du feu et j'en fais autre
chose
et puis avec le temps on va augmenter
l'énergie qu'on va chercher à avoir à
notre disposition a donc je vous le
redis cinq cent mille ans de transition
énergétique ce qui va permettre
d'augmenter la capacité productive de
tout à chacun
donc on extrait plus vite des ressources
et on les transforme plus vite dès qu'on
extrait de l'environnement des
ressources non renouvelables pour les
transformer en autre chose le stock de
ressources non renouvelables baisse
alors au début ils baissent pas dit
encore que il semblerait par exemple que
sur les silex y ait pu y avoir des
pénuries locales au paléolithique
donc on a pu la voir de temps en temps
des pénuries locales de ressources on
rigolait pas parce qu'à l'époque il en
crever et puis avec le temps on a
également compris qu'il y avait une
partie de ce qu on transformait qu'on
pouvait garder pour accélérer la
transformation futur ça s'appelle le
capital donc le capital c'est la partie
de la production qui ne se consomme pas
tout de suite et qui est réutilisable
pour augmenter la production future
alors tout ça est vachement bien nous
croissons et multiplions ont produit de
plus en plus donc on vit de plus en plus
vite
les stocks non renouvelable et puis à un
moment on devient tellement productif
est tellement nombreux qu'on se met
également a commencé à vider les stocks
renouvelables aujourd'hui on a commencé
à vider les stocks d'espèces par exemple
qui étaient renouvelables
on a commencé à vider les stocks de
forêt qui étaient renouvelables
poissons qui étaient renouvelables etc
on commence par la vider les stocks de
sol qui se renouvellent lentement donc
on a commencé à vider un certain nombre
de stocks qui étaient en flammes et puis
j'ai dit transformation j'ai donc dit
énergie mais j'ai dit transformation
j'ai aussi dit sous produits
indésirables de la transformation
quand vous transformez il ya toujours un
moment où vous avez un sous-produit
indésirables de la transformation
ces sous produits indésirables de la
transformation on leur a donné un nom en
français ça s'appelle la pollution donc
la pollution c'est tous les sous
produits indésirables de la
transformation c'est à dire ceux qui
vont avoir un effet que nous ne
recherchons pas et non seulement on ne
recherche pas mais il nous enquiquine
plus tôt donc en gros la pollution c'est
tous les emmerdements est alors dit en
termes plus orthodoxe s'est tous les
produits qu'on va introduire dans
l'environnement et qui vont avoir pour
effet de dégrader la qualité des actifs
restants c'est ça la pollution là dedans
vous pouvez faire rentrer avec cette
définition le changement le changement
climatique l'érosion de la biodiversité
la surpêche et c est alors dans cette
affaire
l'économie que nous avons mises en demie
sur mis sur pied que je vais détailler
dans pas longtemps consiste à compter ce
flux annuel là et a considéré que ya que
ça qui compte
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi donc en
gros on compte le moment où on
transforme puisque la transformation
c'est l'action de l'homme et que
l'argent ne paye que des sommes donc
dans cette affaire là on a décidé que la
sole le seul marqueur de ce flux
physiques du système que je vous
présente là c'est la contrepartie
monétaire du flux de transformation
annuel et ce fut de transformation
annuel dans le jargon des économistes
appellent le pays dès la contrepartie
monétaire
on aurait tout aussi bien pu avoir une
comptabilité qui dirait je compte en
plus ce que je fais en moins ce que je
détruis et puis le jour où la valeur
marginale de la dernière voiture que
j'ai construite est inférieur à la
valeur marginale des derniers bouts de
minerai de fer de minerai de cuivre de
minerai de lithium de tous que de
vanadium de chrome et de combustibles
fossiles que j'ai utilisée pour faire
cette voiture je m'arrête de faire des
voitures et je vis happily ever after
avec les voitures existantes
vous voyez bien que c'est pas ça qu'on
fait en fait le système économique est
un système sans limite absolue
rien dans le système économique ne vous
dit quand le pib atteindra 80 mille
milliards de dollars sur terre ça
s'arrête on a fait un système qui est
potentiellement infini pour ça qu'il est
si séduisant alors pourquoi ce qu'on a
fait ça parce qu'il ya deux siècles
quand on commence à théoriser l'économie
vous avez un certain nombre de gens qui
font l'observation suivante ils disent
l'économie c'est la gestion de ce qui
est rare ce qui est rare ya deux siècles
c'est quoi ces facteurs humains vous
avez plein d'espèces plaint d' espace
plein de monde les etats-unis sont à
peine au début de leur colonisation
la russie est immense et cetera on sait
pas jusqu'où va l'océan
pas de prime de ressources ce qui est
rare ya deux siècles
c'est le facteur humain et donc les
économistes il ya deux siècles à l'image
de monsieur sait qui a écrit très
exactement ce qui est écrit ici et bien
se disent au premier ordre
je vais me contenter de regarder la
limitation venant des hommes
le reste je m'en fous ne compte pas et
si je considère que les ressources sont
infinies vous êtes d'accord avec moi que
toute variation du stock est nul delta
est sur l'infini ça fait toujours zéro
donc je vais compter pour nulle les
facteurs qui ne viennent pas des hommes
approximations au premier rock qui est
toujours celle de l'économie aujourd'hui
donc je vais dire quelque chose qui va
faire beaucoup de peine avec directeur
des études qui vient de rentrer toute
l'économie qu'on vous apprend à l'école
est fausse quand il s'agit d'approcher
le système humain dans sa globalité
quand il s'agit d'approcher des
arbitrages au sein du système humain ça
marche quand il s'agit d'approcher la
totalité des hommes dans leur
environnement
ça ne dit que des bêtises c'est pas fait
pour cent donc dit autrement l'économie
que j'ai apprise à l'école et qu'on
apprend toujours aujourd'hui c'est que
le système productif est alimenté par
deux facteurs de production qui sont le
capital humain et le travail humain et
ça suffit à remplir le supermarché ça ne
tient pas compte des machines ça ne
tient pas compte des ressources alors il
se trouve que à l'époque qu'on aurait pu
gagner la bataille d'une autre manière
il se trouve qu'il ya deux siècles
monsieur charles dupin polytechnicien
dans quelqu'un de très bien baron et a
fait un premier calcul de conversion en
équivalent esclaves alors à l'époque il
appelle pas ça des xkrs la ville appelle
ça des équivalents travailleurs et
monsieur du pain dit je vais regarder en
france et en grande bretagne les moyens
productif dont on dispose en plus d
hommes donc lui il avait tout compris à
la physique et je vais les convertir en
équivalent travailleurs humain donc je
prends la population j'en fais des
travailleurs humains et soit dit en
passant il comptait les enfants pour un
quart les femmes pour un demi et on se
demande si c'est pas de là que vient
l'expression ma moitié quand on parle de
son conjoint
non je vous assure c'est là d'où ça
viendrait sinon ma moitié
alors ça peut être la moitié d'un couple
c'est une autre explication mais ces
fois là on se demande si c'est pas là
que ça vient toujours est il que
toujours est il que donc il prend la
population et il prend également les
auxiliaires que sont à l'époque les
bateaux les moulins et c est donc après
monsieur du pain il dit si je prends la
population et les auxiliaires
alors il devient normal que la grande
bretagne qui a une population à peu près
de la même taille que celle de la france
est déjà une production industrielle
trois fois supérieur c'est normal parce
que il n'ya pas que les hommes qui
travaillent
il ya aussi les moulins les animaux de
trait et les bateaux si à l'époque on
avait écouté monsieur du pain et pas
monsieur sais c'est pas complètement sûr
qu'on aurait construit l'économie de la
même manière ce n'est pas complètement
sûrs et ce que dit le physicien c'est
ils disent que j'ai à droite c'est mais
92 éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
arranger d'une autre manière que ce que
j'avais dans les ressources initial
c'est juste ça le d'accord avec moi y'a
rien d'autre que les 92 éléments du
tableau de mendeleïev dans tous les
objets de la vie courante
rien d'autre on est d'accord sauf qu'on
les a pas trouvés sous cette forme dans
l'environnement
donc je les ai trouvés sous une forme et
je les ai transformé donc pour ça il me
faut trouver mais 92 éléments du tableau
de mendeleïev ça s'appelle les
ressources et les transformer ma
capacité de transformation c'est les
calculs d'ordre de grandeur que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure viens pour un
début ce que des hommes et pour 200
d'iron man
c'est à dire du parc de machines que
nous avons construit c'est mon rapport
de 20 à 200 que je vous ai développé
tout à l'heure le capital dans cette
histoire c'est fait comme le reste c'est
à dire que cet immeuble qui est un
élément de capital a été fait comme le
reste en transformant des ressources
naturelles donc cet immeuble est comme
le reste fait en transformant du minerai
de fer c'est à dire du fer et de
l'oxygène à ranger d'une certaine
manière c'est à dire de des pierres
ressources naturelles c'est à dire de la
peinture ressource naturelle transforme
et c'est donc ces faits exactement de la
même manière
juste ça se détruit pas quand on s'en
sert c'est à dire que pendant que l'on
est dans cette salle pour votre plus
grand plaisir est le mien ça ne
s'effondre pas et là vous comprenez que
y'a pas que les hommes qui sont un
facteur limitant du système dans le
monde moderne
l'énergie est un facteur limitant du
système qui autrement si je prive
d'énergie mon parc de machines je prie
vrai mon système productif de sa
capacité de production
même si les banquiers sont très
sympathiques et même si les chômeurs
sont prêts à aller bosser ça ça ne ça ne
suffit pas dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons
et si je prive le système de ressources
par exemple j'ai pas de poissons à
pêcher le pib de la pêche est nul le pib
de léon de bruxelles est nul il faut
qu'il passe des moules frites au steak
frites mais sinon c'est nul ils etc donc
si vous avez pas les ressources et
d'énergie
vous n'aurez pas la production même si
vous avez des travailleurs très motivés
et même si vous avez des banquiers très
sympathique alors historiquement jusqu'à
maintenant tout ça n'a pas été un
facteur limitant le facteur limitant est
effectivement les hommes vous avez ici
la reconstitution du pib depuis dans
0,17 à dire depuis la naissance de
monsieur jésus-christ alors vous voyez
que tant qu'on n'a pas d'auxiliaire
mécanique en quantités significatives
y a pas de croissance la population est
raisonnablement stable à cette époque là
aussi à cette époque là aussi comme un
homme et productifs comme son système
musculaire n'est pas plus le pays le
plus peuplé du monde a le premier pib de
la planète
essai
la chine sol humain donc la chine
aujourd'hui dit une chose en concert des
nations ai dit écoutez nous fait pas
rire pendant deux millénaires on a été
là puissances économiques dominantes de
la planète
c'est pas parce qu'un siècle de pétrole
a mis les états unis a de place que ça
va changer notre vision du monde donc
d'abord on va retrouver notre place et
ensuite on discute à peu près comme ça
que les choses se présentent très peu
d'auxiliaires mécanique très peu de
croissance
arrivés en masse des auxiliaires
mécaniques et des combustibles fossiles
et crack
les modèles économiques disent que nous
allons avoir trois pour cent de
croissance pour l'éternité
alors ne rigolez pas il se trouve que je
fais partie d'une instance qui s'appelle
le haut conseil pour le climat qu'on
nous a présenté il ya trois semaines la
stratégie nationale bas carbone
élaboré par certains de vos anciens à
qui on a obligé à dire que de diminuer
fortement de diviser par 6 à 7 la
quantité d'énergie fossiles qu'on
rentrerait en france permettrait
d'augmenter le pib français
c'est dedans c'est dedans parce que les
modèles économiques vous dites ça parce
que les modèles économiques peuvent vous
dire que on augmente le pib en divisant
l'énergie par 10 puisque l'énergie est
pas un hymne foot car aucun problème
aucun problème alors en attendant c'est
pas ça qui se passe moi je vous présente
le meilleur modèle macroéconomique du
monde ça fait d'une droite vous avez ici
en abscisse la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par les hommes c'est à dire je
le répète le parc de machines en service
et donc en ordonner la valeur économique
de la production qui suit de façon à peu
près linéaire très simple parents très
sains
c'est valable en valeur absolue c'est
également valable en variation vous avez
ici envers la variation annuelle de la
quantité d'énergie utilisée sur terre
c'est à dire la variation annuelle du
parc de machines en services et en bleu
la variation annuelle de la production
économique humaine
vous voyez que d'autres moyens je te
donne l'autre et donne moi l'autre je te
donne là d'accord je vais vous le dire
autrement
les euro ne font que mesurée
monétairement influent que les
kilowattheures mesure physiquement donc
ces deux unités de compte qui vous
regarde la même chose c'est-à-dire un
flux de transformation je reviens à ma
courbe que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne et je vais en
faire un autre commentaire cette fois
vous voyez que sur l'époque qui va
jusqu'au choc pétrolier
l'approvisionnement énergétique augmente
de 2 10% par an par personne
ça veut dire que le parc de machines par
personne augmente d'au moins 2 et 10 %
par an vous avez un peu d'efficacité
énergétique qui se rajoute ça veut dire
que tant que vous n'avez pas de facteurs
limitants sur les ressources a
transformé la production physique par
personne augmente d'au moins deux et
demi pour cent par an et donc la
contrepartie monétaire de cette
production augmente d'au moins deux et
demi pour cent par an en fait vous allez
voir si un peu plus après les chocs
pétroliers
vous voyez que le rythme se tasse alors
en fait il se tassent totalement pour
les pays de l' ocde ce qu'on appelle les
pays riches les pays occidentaux et le
surplus que vous avez là c'est l'essor
de la chine
puis plus tard des autres pays émergents
et ça se traduit par l'essor de la
quantité de charbon par personne qui est
un effet de moyenne en fait dans les
pays occidentaux la quantité de charbon
utilisé n'augmente pas baisse même un
peu par contre ça explose en chine est
aujourd'hui la chine utilise la moitié
du charbon consommé dans le monde
à ce moment le système commence à
ralentir un peu
c'est à dire que on continue à avoir une
hausse de la production physique par
personne beaucoup plus faible est
beaucoup plus faible que le rythme de
redistribution auquel on s'était habitué
pendant cette époque là c'est à dire
qu'on a organisées dans tous les états
occidentaux du monde
un état providence
+ ou - plus ou moins - providence aux
etats-unis + providence et les
scandinaves mais dans tous les pays du
monde on organise un état providence qui
redistribue une partie de ce qui est
produit et le rythme de croissance de la
redistribution et caler sur le rythme de
croissance de la production c'est-à-dire
quelques pour cent par an et on ne met
pas dans le système de capacité à le
corriger rapidement si la croissance
s'essouffle cirque on ne dit pas aux
fonctionnaires dont on vous prévient si
la croissance s'essouffle les
augmentations à l'ancienneté ça s'arrête
on ne dit pas aux retraités on vous
prévient si le rythme de croissance
s'essouffle automatiquement vous
partirez à la retraite plus tard et
moins bien payés etc etc ne dit pas tout
c'est chaud là on dit pas non si la
croissance s'essouffle continue à vous
payer la même chose il ya vous augmentez
à l'ancienneté de la même manière
à ce moment faut trouver l'argent
quelque part et on s'endette dans tous
les pays occidentaux la dette publique
était inexistante avant les chocs
pétroliers
elle apparaît et se développe enfin très
faible avant les chocs pétroliers
l appareil se développe partout donc
c'est pas juste les politiques français
qui sont des incapables
l appareil se développe partout dans
tous les pays occidentaux après les
chocs pétroliers exactement pour cette
raison là parce que le rythme
d'augmentation de la production par
personne devient insuffisant pour
assurer le rythme de hausse de la
redistribution par personne et à partir
de 2005 et je vous dirai aux cours
prochain pourquoi l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne se met à
devenir à peu près constant à nouveau
dans le monde
en fait ils déclinent dans la zone ocde
je vais vous montrer juste après et
alors là le système part en vrille crise
financière massive de lehman brothers
qui est une conséquence de ce que je
suis en train de vous dire je vais vous
montrer dans pas longtemps
chronologiquement et non une cause
l'endettement se met à exploser on
arrive dans un truc qui est inconnu
depuis très longtemps qui s'appelle les
taux d'intérêts négatifs et c'est donc
le système et ça c'est la réponse du
système a fait que on a bâti quelque
chose qui dépend des de l'abondance
énergétique et que cette abondance
énergétique commence à petite vitesse
aujourd'hui à petite vitesse aujourd'hui
à s'effilocher et d'ici à ce que vous
ayez mon âge on va passer la
surmultipliée dans ce domaine là donc
c'est pour ça que votre avenir
ce ne sera pas la prolongation
tendancielle du passé alors quelques
courbes pour finir vous avez ici la
variation du pib par personne dans le
monde de la production économique par
personnes dans le monde depuis 1960
vous voyez cette ici cette affaire en
variation annuelle
et puis je vous ai mis en orange des
moyennes sur trois périodes qui sont
jusqu'au choc pétrolier entre le choc
pétrolier 79 et le choc pétrolier de
2007 2008 et depuis le choc de 2007 2008
il ya un petit artefacts dont je vais
pas vous parler aujourd'hui parce que
c'est trop long mais l'endettement est
quelque chose qui permet de faire du pib
sans production
c'est un peu compliqué mais donc ça ici
vous avez commencé à avoir un effet de
bord ce que vous voyez c'est que à
l'époque des trente glorieuses l'énergie
croit fortement par personne et la
production par personne croit encore
plus fortement puisqu'il ya le gain
d'efficacité d'énergétique entre les
deux les ingénieurs s'affairent une
voiture plus efficace avec la même
quantité de pétrole qui avance avec
moins de pétrole si c'est la même
voiture ou une voiture plus grosse
vendus plus chers avec la même quantité
de pétrole après vous voyez l'énergie
par personne augmente moins vite c'est
plutôt 1% en fait le 05 et vous voyez
que le pib par personne ce faire croître
moins vite et depuis l'épisode alors
c'est très contrastées là vous quand
vous voyez aussi qu'il ya un grand
épisode de volatilité vix la baisse en
fait vous avez deux régions dans le
monde qui évolue de manière très
discriminés à partir de ce moment-là
l'oscd eux et le reste et je vais vous
montrer là où nous vivons c'est à dire
l'os et des eaux alors lancé des oeufs
voilà ici comment évolue un premier
morceau de l' ocde c'est à dire l'union
européenne dans laquelle nous vivons
jusqu'au choc pétrolier
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne augmente fortement entre les
chocs pétroliers 2006 eweek le maximum
et en 2006 deux ans avant lehman
brothers s'est pas lehman brothers qui a
provoqué la crise économique qui a fait
baisser la quantité d'énergie utilisée
c'est la contraction de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
disponible qui a ralenti le pib et qui a
rendu incapable les emprunteurs de
rembourser la dette qu'ils avaient
commencé à contracter au moment où
l'économie a ralenti une première fois
ici 1
un fusil à de détente là on commence à
s'endetter pour compenser le fait que
l'énergie s'arrête d'augmenter et là au
moment où l'énergie commence à baisser
on n'a même plus la capacité à se ré
endetter à la bonne vitesse pour
rembourser la pyramide de ponzi qu'on
avait commencé à créer pardon là vous
voyez un effet du truc dont je vous
parlerai la prochaine fois qu'ils aient
la réalimentation du marché mondial de
l'énergie à partir des pétroles et gaz
de roche mère aux états unis farah
pétrole sont ce que vous voyez en europe
à ce moment c'est le pib par personne
augmente fortement au moment des trente
glorieuses l'énergie par personnes
s'arrêtent de croître mais le pib par
personne continue d'augmenter et vous
voyez que depuis 2006 l'augmentation est
quasi nulle et soit dit en passant la
production industrielle de l'europe
aujourd'hui est toujours inférieure à ce
qu'elle était en 2007
les tonnes kilomètres en camion
aujourd'hui en europe sont inférieur à
ce qu'elle était en 2007 l' indice de la
construction aujourd'hui en europe est
inférieur à ce qu'il était en 2007 donc
une partie de l'augmentation du pib
qu'on a eu depuis 2007 c'est du faux pib
c'est une c'est un artefact de
comptabilité qui en gros qui est une
mauvaise correction de l'inflation
tu veux dire autrement alors à ce moment
vous demander aux grands bretons est ce
que vous êtes contents les grands
bretons vous dise non je vous rappelle
qu'un référendum en général vous
répondez à celui qui pose la question
vous ne répondez pas à la question de
gaulle l'a appris à ses dépens et d'une
manière générale quand vous quand vous
demandez est du reste le premier
référendum qui a eu en france sur la
constitution européenne vous rappelez du
résultat donc on a reposé la question
d'une autre manière mais donc le
référendum
historiquement c'est quand même un très
bon moyen de répondre à celui qui pose
la question et non pas la question
donc les anglais disent à celui qui pose
la question on n'est pas content de la
façon dont les choses se passent
soit dit en passant
à partir du moment où le pib par
personne augmente plus et où vous créer
un espace de libre circulation dans une
zone où vous avez une différence de 1 à
5 entre ce que gagnent les gens à l'est
est ce que gagnent les gens à l'ouest
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il se passe
ça s'équilibre alors quand vous êtes
dans un univers en expansion c'est pas
grave parce que vous pouvez augmenter
les revenus des gens d'un côté pendant
que vous continuez à augmenter ou au
moins vous de diminuer pas les revenus
des gens de l'autre côté donc quand
l'espagne et le portugal rentrer dans
l'union européenne à une époque de forte
croissance le pouvoir d'achat des
français peut continuer à augmenter en
même temps que le pouvoir d'achat des
espagnols augmente fortement
mais quand vous faites rentrer en 2005
c'est à dire deux ans ou un an avant le
maximum énergétique européen les pays de
l'est en leur disant venez dans la danse
votre pib va augmenter en même temps que
le nôtre va continuer à augmenter plaque
crack l'énergie par personne se met à
baisser à ce moment le pib de la zone
documente plus vote effet de vases
communicants s'applique et tout ce que
les pays de l'est
comprendre c'est les pays où est-ce
qu'ils vont le perdre c'est mécanique
alors il ya deux manières de le perdre
le plombier polonais vient à londres et
ça vous donne ce résultat là est la
deuxième manière de le perdre c'est
renault investit en roumanie et à ce
moment vous avez les ouvriers français
qui gueule et c'est les deux manière
dont le processus de rééquilibrage
s'applique c'est que le début tant qu'on
restera je suis pas en train de faire de
la politique à deux balles mais juste en
train de vous dire que tant qu'on
restera dans un espace dans lequel
chacun circulent et paye comme il veut
alors que vous avez des différences de
potentiel initial que vous ne pouvez pas
homogénéiser par le haut vous allez
avoir des rééquilibrages avec la perte
pour un certain nombre de gens donc la
tentation du frac site de l'italique
site du de l'espace sith et de chez pas
quoi et de la suède sites vont augmenter
toutes ces pressions vont augmenter à
cause de ça est à l'origine vous trouver
l'énergie
quand vous faites une analyse de
tendance vous constatez soit dit en
passant que cette variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne en fait elle est héritière
d'une tendance très lourde et je vais
revenir dessus au prochain cours qui
s'exprime depuis des décennies ici vous
avez une courbe qui vous donne la
variation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'union européenne donc
c'est pas son approvisionnement c'est sa
variation depuis 50 ans ce que vous
voyez c'est que la variation avec des
grands écarts 1 est ce une tendance soit
les fortes un peu moins
forte un peu moins forte un peu moins
forte un peu moins fort pia un moment on
rentre en territoire négatif et à ce
soit dit en passant à ce moment là on se
met à avoir quelque chose qui est
raisonnablement volatile si on se dit
que cette dérive et seconde a de bonnes
raisons d'être représentative de la
dynamique interne du processus
à ce moment vous vous dites la suite de
l'histoire c'est que l'approvisionnement
énergétique va continuer à baisser et
donc le taux de croissance du pib qui
était de plus en plus faibles sur la
même période va continuer à baisser est
passé en territoire durablement négatif
donc la vie qui vous attend et moi pour
les quelques décennies si tout se passe
bien virgule également à toutes les
chances de ne ressembl ait en rien à ce
que j'ai connu depuis que je suis née
c'est à dire que ça ne sera pas un monde
d'expansion ça sera un monde de
contraction donc on va avoir besoin de
votre génie créatif
parce que je vous assure que de gérer un
monde en contraction c'est autrement
plus redoutable comme exercice
d'optimisation sous contrainte que de
gérer un nombre expansion donc on va
vraiment avoir besoin de vous on a aussi
besoin de moi mais on va vraiment avoir
besoin de vous au sens où on va vraiment
avoir besoin des cervelles le bio
sélectionnés du pays pour s'attaquer à
un des problèmes les plus durs qu'on va
avoir à résoudre qui est de garder un
système à peu près stables dans un
contexte de contraction des ressources
disponibles
je peux vous assurer que ce que vous
avez vu à l'écrit et à l'oral du
concours c'est de la petite bière à côté
de ça je prends la zone ocde dans son
ensemble et je vais finir par ça même
motif même punition
l'approvisionnement augmente pas
personnes augmente jusqu en 79 passe par
un maximum en 2006 et c'est aussi vrai
aux états unis aux états unis
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne est passée par un maximum deux
ans avant lehman brothers j'insiste et
vous avez également cette évolution qui
en fait reflète une évolution en
tendance qui a pris place depuis très
longtemps et donc il va
vraisemblablement se passer à peu près
la même chose dans cette zone là puis
dans le monde dans son ensemble
voilà donc ce que je vous ai raconté au
cours de ce premier
module c'est que le monde dans lequel
nous vivons a notamment été permis pas
que mes a notamment été permis par le
fait que nous avons trouvé gratuitement
sous nos pieds
des poches de soleil comme le dit très
joliment yann arthus bertrand c'est à
dire de l'énergie fossile gratuite avec
un très fort pouvoir calorifique donc
une très grande capacité exothermique
qui nous a permis de transformer à
vitesse accélérée la totalité des autres
sources tout aussi gratuite que nous
avons trouvés sur terre et ça nous a
permis de construire le système socio
économique dans lequel vous avez grandi
c'est à dire l'essentiel des gens en
ville
l'essentiel des gens dans des activités
de services tout le monde mange en du
steak à tous les repas les gens ayant
énormément de temps libre et les
revendications de la baie du medef et de
la cgt auxquels on peut faire droit sans
problème c'est ça le monde dans lequel
on a grandi et soit dit en passant
le programme d'échangés internationaux
de mines paristech puisqu'il faut des
avions pour ça et la manière dont je
comptabilise le flux de transformation
est une manière que j'ai construite par
construction sans limites puisque le
seul truc qui était vraiment emmerdant
dans la sphère c'est à dire le fait que
la terre fait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre et pas 14000 et pas quinze
mille jeux les passer sous silence foutu
ça sous le tapis et sur la base de cet
axiome qui dès qu'une approximation au
premier ordre
j'ai raffiné mais vision depuis deux
siècles mais sans remettre en cause un
accès au fondamental qui est que la
nature est gratuite donc évidemment je
vois pas cette limite puisqu'elle n'est
pas dans le système au prochain cours on
ne regardera pas ça qui est un des
premiers facteurs limitants du système
c'est-à-dire la pollution et on va se
concentrer sur une pollution bien
particulière qui s'appelle le changement
climatique alors le changement
climatique n'est que la conséquence aval
de ce flux de transformation ont
prochain course qu'on regardera vraiment
c'est le goulet d'étranglement qui peut
éventuellement s'appliquer en amont du
système et qui s'appelle
l'approvisionnement en énergie fossile
on pourrait évidemment si on avait le
temps regardez l'approvisionnement en
métaux c'est un d'autres facteurs
limitants possible du système
l'approvisionnement en espèces c'est un
autre facteur limitant possible du
système etc
mais donc on va regarder
on va disserter sur l'approvisionnement
ah bon en combustibles fossiles c'est à
dire en capacité de transformation
voilà donc c'est ça le tableau dans
lequel on va se situer pour le prochain
cours auquel je vous donne rendez vous
bonne soirée
[Musique]